no but yeah
yeah i like to do it in here get it
working out here you gotta turn it on i
can't hear it
oh why i don't know anything about what
we're doing but okay there's not a uh
thing
all right
try talking into it how about now yeah
you're good okay is that a right that's
about right yeah yeah we're okay
pat's not gonna talk start with the
prayers okay yeah so we're gonna do that
you're in i mean we're gonna do one line
each person does one line around the
table one line do you have another i
mean even if he had another mic i
couldn't plug it in it's all it's all
plugged we're max out of the h6 you know
max capac your mic uh
looks
like
disabled
dude i thought that was a dog barking
but it was this dope
how do you do this best christmas song
ever man this one yeah this is the uh
what how to play it's like
i feel like i don't it's like but i know
i've played but i might it was at my
friend's river house and i was likely
drunk it's like a very intense
do you think yeah it's a building
yeah absolutely
i think it's good for the podcast
absolutely
okay that's active listening so you're
welcome that's just a great technique
you're so right having a toothbrush it's
too bright we had a lot of conversations
going on yeah absolutely
okay copy let's all okay each do one
conversation okay so what i was thinking
was you guys keep going we're all doing
it at the same time okay but you're
still doing the prayer yeah i wanna do
the prayer errol can you start the
prayer for us
everyone does one line of this prayer of
course errol is the prayer guy yeah it's
cool i think it's a good i feel like i
mean stereo or uh typecast already and
i'm
fine with it
i'm excited for this let's let's let's
start it are we going your way just so i
know i want to know we'll go this way
okay
everyone dear um
yeah please just join us in a moment do
whatever you want
okay
here we go
dear uh
you know
think about it
and um
and then whatever that is who may make
concerns yeah
yeah thank you all right dear
representative whoever
is in charge of this
i don't know if you're a guy a
woman you just are i think you just are
yeah i think so too
so we're all god yeah we are all our god
i will pray to you guys all right let's
pray to each other i mean yeah if you
you are one so it's like you gotta pray
to you know
yourself too we just start a cult
what happened
you sit down and play a game of catan
and you start a cult this is great
pretty much exactly what i'm trying to
avoid hey go cold
oh sure color wise do you like orange i
prefer this color
blue happens to be my favorite color so
hot biscuits
winner
i pray to the catan lords bless this
game yeah we didn't even do this thing
though i mean can you guys stick with
this she distracted us with you yeah it
was
this is what's so exciting this game is
like so uh by this by the prayer
the
the overlord of the
of the universe is gonna give us one of
us the most fortune
yeah there's a blessing and a curse
genie what about the person that comes
in last do you think they should feel
bad
but it's just like it's just like uh you
know
all the way the only way you know
maybe next time
that's how you feel knowing what the
good times are yeah that's how everyone
says you don't know when the good times
are it's like well
yeah
yes
yeah that's a good point too
oh my god i like the easiest these ones
look like a little canvas
christmas stuff oh is it my turn yeah
errol already did his uh okay let's just
oh we're just calling it there
let's just think about it what is a god
is it male 1 yeah you know that is a
whole other thing
i mean
how is santa related to god i think is a
good question what does santa is
directly what are your thoughts on that
riley so santa i feel like is god's
older brother who's kind of like a
slouch there
like he's not your brother
i think it's just brother brother
brother yeah i could see that he's like
he's like i'll just like you know give
away [ __ ] that's like that's what i'll
do and god's like okay i'll just i'll
just make everything then you know
you can help out a little
and guys just and uh
santa's he's like he's a hype man he
doesn't want he doesn't want the heat
you know god's like i'm doing it all for
this it's all coming back to me it's
going to be amazing
brother's like can i just give [ __ ] out
and just be okay with my [ __ ] and just
chill he's tired dude he just made all
this [ __ ] okay and now you want him to
dull it out it's like a bunch of slaves
i'm just gonna execute that and it's
gonna be santa's like i'll make all the
kids [ __ ]
yeah yeah only strictly kid [ __ ] nothing
else yeah that's crazy god's like i'll
make the rivers and the mountains
oh i'll just make uh here's a legos
yeah
here's the whole lego set of a forest oh
yeah right
damn
i got more money on
god inventing legos than i do him
inventing volcanoes that's what i'm just
saying dollars to donuts
honestly i can see him closer to doing
legos you know what i mean it's kind of
weird but i see what you're saying yeah
thank you
appreciate your belt
no i like that so that was riley's turn
so we're not doing rules first for sure
no i mean why would we no one needs a
refresher why is there so much passive
passive aggressiveness to the table
past passive regret i thought we were
doing the prayer
okay
i think this is how is it
this is the prayer
wow whoa
we're already going deep i thought i was
the medic coach you know what i'm saying
oh
[ __ ] watch out
she didn't even take her coach off her
coat off yet
maybe
maybe i did maybe i invented it did you
take coach still on you
know i think just kind of coaches only
what am i doing we're rolling to see
who's going to happen you bet we are
just turning i think uh
teachers teach first grade always first
class class
nope
i keep doing that
all right there i already died you're
left where are you what whoa that wasn't
in a role it was just a place
your number not my favorite plastic bag
damn that's a good number not my
favorite
what
um i like 13 or odds or you got the
highest numbers or rebel or three like
anything below 18. right oh that's
okay that's
surprise surprise
18 oh [ __ ] you guys rigged it so i go
first
i like but like
any any like threes i feel like threes
and odds and uh primes except two three
is a money number it's it's a doy you
know someone said uh it looks like boobs
my first heart is just like a dog loves
this game
[ __ ] autistic
i don't think this game is very fun
oh wait is this the thing what game do
you play oh [ __ ] what is that yeah pick
up your mind oh that's great
can i hear you or watch
it right now they can't hear you really
just can't they can't hear you but it's
not good yeah sounds terrible yeah you
want your voice to be pure and beautiful
i know i agree let me just yeah if you
hear it you'll see what i mean exactly
well here we go you'll hear what i mean
not very true all right we're hoping for
fortunately today it's gonna be hard
it's not i got it
this isn't a difference to the weak and
it takes from the strong oh yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah it's back there i'm just
kind of in the background it's not good
enough it's annoying it's like trying to
like
like
uh punch someone when you're sleeping
you're like
that's what you sound like it's like a
weak punch i'm punching someone when i'm
they're sleeping i'm sleeping when
you're in a dream and you're trying to
punch and you can't do it isn't that so
frustrating
oh it's sort of like what
yeah like your body shuts off your
ability to move your body when you're
sleeping so that you don't like hurt
yourself when you're dreaming so
sometimes you feel that when you're
dreaming so then you're you feel
immobile i've never done that i've never
had that in a dream how do you know
others do this actualized person this
may just be you wow am i that would be
kind of cool not a me thing i've read
about it i'm a self-actualized person
dude that is the coolest thing okay okay
i get it very happy you're like the can
you turn mine down i'm not happy yeah
holly jolly
god damn it hans needs to either stop
doing drugs or do more yeah that's open
uh
i like jesus's shirt i think so that's a
good thing to say to jesus at any point
whether you like his shirt or not you
know what i mean like i don't know if i
know he wants to be the guy like me i
like jesus but his shirt choice you know
what are you talking about come on
no it wants yeah we try to have one
conversation
oh sorry we're talking about um
forgetting
i thought 9 11 is like
i'm saying about the 9 11 forget and
forgive
forgetting forgiveness let bygones be
bygones
it was an honest mistake why are you
hiding out in that hole like we we
forgive you
come on you know we're gonna forget
about that
we're being honest
i guess thank you there's bathrooms in
there we're so weird
it's just a cool
pair
because every day you hear the same way
but then if you put this on you work a
little differently
but now they just have one jesus's voice
is way too high
my voice is too high can you [ __ ] that
down a little bit why i think i mean
just pitch wise like you're very shrieky
uh shrieky
yeah
or maybe your ideology is a little
grating oh that could be it
i get that last time jesus was hammered
he was crucified damn that's a joke
that's a joke
whoa what if he actually wasn't spoiled
a [ __ ] his water
water turns to wine and his body is 70
water so he's probably just hammered all
the time dude yeah well he would be dead
i read that in a book for sure
i mean he can't jesus can do anything
it's
survive alcohol poisoning
i wonder if yeah his tolerance must be
really high on that like he doesn't he
wouldn't even have the same speed
party tonight bring water
wink wink
damn do you think i bet jesus is like a
really [ __ ] like frat guy either was
probably like really cool or really not
cool
wow yeah wide open
uh loves christmas
jesus does yes i mean he never
celebrated it so yeah he did no he did
it it's his birthday that's yes that's a
different holiday no yeah legitimately
would it be easter if there was no
bunny and no eggs and no yeah he also
died that day or whatever or he came
back so
on that exact day
same thing with december 25th he
celebrated it completely differently
stole easter from do you think he knew
that it would be christmas we still
talking santa yeah and he was like i'm
gonna do a little christmas trend
they're gonna have no idea but people in
the future will know
what jesus what what
yeah charlie brown can you say that one
more time though
he knew that uh they would celebrate
christmas
like that in the future so on his
birthday he would be like having little
presents and be like
these people don't know it's been
celebrated the same way
since
that very day jesus is santa
maybe
there you go yeah like um because that
would make sense like he just starts he
gives so much and this is berta is
obviously going to give the most
so
so after he dies
i don't even see that one oh man this mr
pip extra
you should have done this spam what do
you call this should i block him yeah
you're just doing weird stuff what does
that mean lester and phil holes whoa
it's mr pimp extra
extra wow
what a coincidence i was just showing up
honestly some really crazy things have
been happening lately in the universe
that are just like
wow kind of donkey doing really weird
coincidences and stuff i think i've
unlocked i think i've unlocked um
manifestation is what i think it is
oh yeah
i'm a meta coach dude i gotta teach
people how to get there no yeah you're
you're
you've got it try to manifest a
conversation oh yeah that one's i can't
do that on my own you guys got to help
me out boom it's so hard to manifest you
gotta i timed mr pip extra out
yeah jihad bdsm brides timed out for 300
seconds this is your punishment for 300
seconds mr pip extra everybody i can't
believe you shut up that it's like such
a waste of a year a shot name or
something or something is that how it
works power because great wrestling if
your name is mr
extra and then you're just the guy that
spams like that i mean you could really
do something with that you know what i
mean
you got a whole soda company behind you
all right
soap what are you talking about
mr pibb extra uh
yeah he's um he's a good guy he's a good
guy
yeah he's just a little lost riley or
how are you feeling would you say inside
just give me an emotion i feel warm
i feel like it's your turn oh yeah
do you know how to play
so let's do a little primer the more
dots there are in the vertex the more
valuable the spot so these pick this
spot then there's five
three four that's nine dots if you pick
this spot it's five
seven nine dots if you pick this spot
it's nine ten eleven dots so this would
be more precious but you want rock
that's the most precious overall in
general you know wait
so right here it would be what sort of
five nine oh okay 10 11. copy
and this spot
rock is the most valuable and sheep is
the least valuable
try to roll in the box this is good
that's a good rundown let's hit it and
you're trying to get 10 points and you
can trade four resources in for one of
any resource for resource equal one
resource let's say that again you're
trying to get ten points
to get one
and you gotta build settlements two away
from each other
equals one catan point you need twenty
katan points to one don't listen all
right [ __ ]
all right you know what i'll figure it
out later
uh the okay quick question two the
houses that didn't that no they have to
go house roadhouse right what's you just
put your
house yeah
your old friend here um
yeah i get it kind of let's get it i
mean i'm happy to play against
self-interest if you want to play that
game i'll send you out he plays hard he
goes hard yeah no i'm gonna do it myself
actually he looks like he hurt sheep
okay
everyone keeps talking about sieve maybe
we should play sid
everyone's just talking about
shiv
yeah
civilization
i don't know
um i thought that was a computer game
yeah we could all bring a laptop so we
could have a lan party
oh that'd be fun
um
or you could play mousetrap oh also fun
yeah
mousetrap i could see traffic was the
last time you played build a mouse crap
house what it's been a long time
since the mousetrap page
no i actually really i don't think i
ever played it
i i would always want to play it
uh but every time i played it like the
pieces would be scattered for a lot of
setup and yeah man yeah
and be people that had mousetrap because
i never had it
i don't remember i definitely played it
and hurting animals
yeah
that's funny because his mom's a hippie
but we actually did trap mice and drugs
and
they have to pull resources or something
so sorry
so you pick a
so now you put down a settlement on a
road okay
do i i don't i don't need to roll or
anything
what did you say
i didn't see that he put his house down
i think your energy's rubbing off on me
what's my energy dude what do you mean
why are you blaming me for this [ __ ]
dude you're really weird
what the [ __ ] what's wrong right now
i'm doing [ __ ] um
i haven't used a sweatshirt on and it's
[ __ ] changing lives
if errol agrees not to start a cult hans
has to agree to start a cult yeah okay
you can do the cult you want all the
chicks isn't that your thing yeah so you
started yeah you start the call it just
turns out you have to listen to me
because i want to run over [ __ ] that's
not just about getting chicks other [ __ ]
cooler i know you everyone needs to
listen to you you're like rasputin
no no one needs to listen to me i'm just
saying i got some good ideas there's
just a lot i can't i can't multitask
i don't want to
debate
gingerbread over uh point on the spot
and we'll tell you if it's good or not
i've showed you that's a good spot
okay
uh gingerbread is like this one i was
looking over there but those aren't
really valuable
this is pretty good yeah that was my
next that was my first show
strawberry is not that good that's eight
ten dollars that's nine twelve dollars
something about it yeah two more dollars
probably caught in the nostalgia of
gingerbread uh yeah i think that's good
i like cheddar i like it as
yeah you got to build two away
yeah so you got to build here and the
same way about bricks we're
uh here were you guys riffing about
we were riffing about uh oh damn
gingerbread or shortbread
hey just watch the punch man that's just
uh
oh we should appreciate the music
probably
gingerbread's chill but it's like you
only really want it sometimes so i guess
we had to too it was just shortbread
that's true
but there is a time for it versus
shortbread
true
i mean it's only sometimes i just don't
like cheese i think it's a holiday also
it's not a bread it's a cookie
that's just is it a bread i love it i
feel like no it's not a bread but maybe
that's just why they called it them it
was like a form of like a
you know it's a marketing it's a second
it's a short bread it takes a lot less
time
it's a
it's a third
third bread cousin
one yeast removed
you're on a yeast kick tonight
you're really yeasty
got him you're are you seeing him he
looks like
giant yeast
so here's what gareth i mean had his
stomach out tonight that's what i'm
saying it looked like a pizza dough like
a
it looked liquid
it looked pleasing but not on a human
body
what an interesting
i mean don't you think whiteness is a
sign of weakness
yeah in some ways yeah definitely
it's not ideal it's not the ideal skin
color no it's too fragile in the sun
but then they have this fighting spirit
about them they're just
you know that's angry yeah
like i just want to take everything yes
i mean i guess that's one that's the
only big drawback is your skin i mean
there's lots of others but that one
that's a good
families
that's everyone uh white people
especially i just want to do more uh
binocular riffs oh yeah the binoculars
yeah you're killing me hey yeah light up
binoculars hey i can see you guys
through
i can uh
see you guys through the
camera this binoculars go so far
um
this is riley uh it's your turn
again yeah no these are like uh yeah it
is
no because the arrow hasn't gone yet
yeah exactly it goes from me uh
from riley oh to
yeah because then the first person goes
last and the last person gets to go
twice so they have priority spots no i
meant more in like a meta way i just was
checking in it's real so it's good we're
just checking in
um so i can't build just to confirm i
can't oh [ __ ] i can't build this way
right
it can yeah
you just you're just picking a spot with
a lot of dots again you're doing the
same thing you did here oh
oh
[ __ ] okay that's a good point
hands
hands is the katan app worth it hands
hands
the katana
is back dude yeah i blocked them for
five six hundred seconds it seemed to
calm them down what's up mr pibb
mr pitt what's up boy
hans thoughts on geology
yeah they want to do it
i got to do it dr pepper for me for
peace out nerves
whoa where's the small one
he ate it
he's licking it right now
that dog actually actually hurt his toe
i can't do that the dog is a small dog
yeah
so that you're more in the shot
you want to switch me smaller
back a little bit
but i couldn't go here
don't want to be on camera anymore i
could just that's not
okay yeah that's a good point
oh [ __ ]
i uh i just dick
i don't want that on camera
wow that just happened
i saw it
errol's turn don't yell at me man so
pick up the resources from your second
settlement so pick up these three right
here let's go
christmas airline
so i get the number of cards right here
barrel arrow yeah no just one of each
yeah
this one
errol carols
wow
welcome to errol's couch
i will [ __ ] your wife
dude
i will not bathe in patchouli oil and
recite the bhagavad-gita
why did you pick up a thing dude
uh that was my second you already you're
no i mean uh you're you're first yeah
we haven't gone all the way around yet
oh well i already won yeah take it back
take it back think about it i went i
thought it was my turn it wasn't it i
already got yelled at about it so
i said did you go you oh yeah and you're
gonna pick up your second settlement and
then i was uh pat's turn my second goal
45 minutes
it's a podcast it's only been going on
for 25 minutes oh yeah that's a long
time considering we haven't started just
one of me that's how katan works
well it's because you went when you
weren't supposed to go in such incidents
like that
and we're also having a podcast in the
middle think about it dude
goofed it up
my two front teeth have you ever done
one where you play two games of scrabble
that sounds like a real nanogram
we do bananagrams but i like scrabble
best how do you like your eggs in the
morning scrabbled
someone's offering money check in i
can't see [ __ ]
on lsd dmt all the time
all the time
i'm going to see if honda's bilingual
was it a big one or not hans you told me
you didn't do drugs for fifty dollars
twenty two houses on lsd dmt all the
time that's actually true
i've only seen them once not on lsd or
dmt all right
let's keep flying
i don't like this shot it just looks
like i'm literally just staring at
nothing
i just at least want like a hat and
that's my sunglasses on or something you
can do that yeah you can be that guy i
mean because i can't
yeah be that guy i mean look at my shot
like look i'm i'm literally talking at
myself look how weird this looks i think
it doesn't look bro
what's going on you knew where the
camera was dude i didn't put it together
it's my bad for sure
yeah no i [ __ ] up and i'm just trying
to undo it you know what i mean it's
fine you look
you're sitting there
the the camera is just capturing reality
like the homeless damn is that the most
offensive part it feels like it it hurts
a little more
what is wrong what's this
you're doing great i love what you're
doing right now i don't think you should
it's the most emotion
i think it's time for another prayer
quick mid game prayer quick boom great
prayer
you're the sweetest man you're just a
nice hey guys uh you guys
hearted son of a guy
i don't know i don't know
we know covet is rough for some of you
you know things are tough right now
you're trying to visit your families
maybe
your families are with you right now
mm-hmm but here at the uh
who's associates
curtis nelson
uh here
here at the house here at the household
we believe in one true value and that is
the cabinets don't slam
always
love thy
neighbor's wife
all the people you could love
why your neighbor's wife love your
mcdonald's
local mcdonald's show them some support
this holiday season
this guy in the middle looks like an old
king strategizing for his last siege
who pat
the arrow yeah
dude yeah you look like an old yeah like
an old i shall not lose my kingdom again
generous bring me goodness
yeah yeah yeah i come back yeah
you can't get this [ __ ] anywhere yeah
these are some special dyes where'd you
guys try to replicate this sweater dude
someone just gave you money it's hard
that's real interesting that is your
turn real indigo oh yeah
what the [ __ ] is this dude is america
still a big a big producer of indigo
i'm the guy that goes on radio and goes
pretty in this it was a crop that was
from yeah i know you know that part no i
am no i didn't even mean it
maybe
maybe i should stop saying right what i
really mean is just go on
go
yeah
we pick up our second settlements now uh
did you do that try to like keep it up
try to hold it like this for sure no
stop looking at my card cards
i know this is the secret you guys are
watching me pick these cards that's not
a secret now i'll try to keep your cards
face down other than you know your [ __ ]
man
we're doing good why do i have to keep a
face why can't you you're right no it's
all about open
information and uh yeah we should all be
one with the universe yeah i am one with
and then riley rolls the dice
started why did you pick up
can you uh pick up the second settlement
you already did that oh yeah i know but
i thought you meant the other one no
yeah just
okay undo what you left did the the most
recent time i haven't had a silent night
in my life
that's the worst time to be scared when
you're asleep
right all right
you can't even sleep just scared
that's a good point
you uh
have nightmares
i really don't i have uh i think i can
i've had like one nightmare or two maybe
my nightmares now are just about me
getting [ __ ] up i'm like drunk in my
dreams whoa yeah hey that doesn't sound
that bad it's not bad but it's like when
you're struggling with sobriety it's
kind of not chill oh yo that is nacho
yeah
but it's fine it's so it's a nice way to
keep in your dreams
no i've never made one we're supposed to
be paying attention to this chat thing
i think they're getting pissed at us
dudes oh yeah they hate us you're not
supposed to pay attention to that
why didn't you give me that rule i
thought you were the nice guy it's up to
you if you want to so five was rolled
so if you have a house on a five you
pick up one of that settlement one of
that resource
yeah i did that i already have them
no he would just roll the five so if you
have a five on any of these all right
then you pick up that right he's playing
it oh yeah yeah where's the other five
sure five here is that another five
you're wearing a lot of clothes
sometimes you say something and
it's racist what you got you got a
hoodie and a shirt on i got a jacket and
a shirt on same thing
i've got a
even losers dream dude
yeah losers dream about being losers
yeah are you done riley also enjoying
good times i forgot what i wrote
hey hans you're god's calculator you're
not going to buy anything right
10.
sick nice
nice i'm going off so if you have
anything on a tent
then you pick it up
cool
tens right here
just like that
it's like that
okay wow
a bountiful
harvest for me
you know
plugging it up
yeah you don't want to be breaking the
by bylaws of katan
no it's like a craps table
can we all think our
lord and savior
sneezes christ
thank you thank you kleenex campaign
yeah you should pitch it yeah yeah
all right guys
jesus christ yeah and then like your
your major marketing days are christmas
and easter you can have uh
14 days of sneezing six hours or weeks
ten ten days of christmas eight days
night that's monica on the first
twelve
at night
and a
vaccine for
the government
it's a classic and the vaccine to track
you go to work
that's good let's make this that's
actually
that's actually really good
we should uh you should pitch that are
you guys getting the booster
yeah december 29th yeah i'm gonna get
boosted booster
yeah
this guy knows what he's going to boost
these shoes you get it because
the boost is also slang to steel you
guys know that we got an eight i got a
boost
damn got him dude that's great
it's
maybe your left hand could be used next
time i always appreciate you
telling me about efficiencies you just
move this should we make christmas
cookies
i'm trying to make a better podcast
i'm sorry it's okay bye felicia
doing great settlers of katanas like
riley it never finishes boom got him
whoa i'm not doing that
it shall be six
a six and the lord said
then it shall be it is uh it's been a
pretty uh
my people are gonna starve
it's been a rough one it's been a yeah
you got an eight recently
boosters are for sheep get boosted baba
thank you you gotta pay attention [ __ ]
this game
okay dude my people will die hans jesus
christ i mean i picked up a brick
all right is it riley's turn
get boosted bubba
get the nike air boost again are you
[ __ ]
all right you know what it's gonna go
i'm gonna it's me fine hey i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get where did you get that
from
whoa
is there a chipotle you're a magician
he just made that that's crazy so quick
should have had one for everyone
yeah
one bite
no oh no
um
i'll keep my mouth shut
i'm gonna get boosted on the
am
christmas
right folks donate five dollars if
you're feeling the christmas spirit
i'm gonna sing your song if you if you
believe in the lord
you shall give five dollars
can i get a five dollar [ __ ] don't
believe me plant the seed and that seed
will
prosper
that five dollar seed
all right give me money if you want a
good christmas
oh i'm not i'm not paying attention
this is bad
for me nine okay nine okay i got a four
okay thank you thank you i am
mr pibb extras being a dirty little see
you next tuesday again
again how much is this
spamming how much does a square foot
cost like 70 dollars oh i don't know who
wants wood because i was thinking
a five it's only five dollars for
something
some wood oh yeah
i'll be there this guy's going to buy
you a diet dp
what did you just that's so nice of that
candace i was just curious about it i
like this is such a cool house and i've
never seen like diet dr pepper like on
in stock and i said let me try it and
it's actually very gross
yeah i don't want any diet duct tape you
want hans to cleanse your sins donut
five dollars now
oh [ __ ]
okay i'm tripping
are you actually gonna play or what
i think they think you're mikey
uh candace what mikey
i don't know biggs
i don't know what they're talking about
what do you say
mikey um maybe that's you
oh maybe i'm liking my mom
i was just saying because you're a hat
you look like a character on recess
dandy i love spinelli thank you
i'm done okay are you reilly
if you
uh
want to repress your sins donate five
dollars what's the trade in value again
you need four of an individual asset to
trade it i'll split it up
okay question
um
we can only reap the benefits of where
our settlement is right or our house
yeah i can't take the benefit of other
people's settlements
yeah
i'm gonna build a homeless settlement so
he built the he rolled a 10 so
attendants are here and here yeah i
don't have anything there yeah i'm just
i'm going to just not it's not going to
go well for my people it's okay
you're doing fine i've let them down i
do need to make some trades i don't know
riley already built the city but
everyone else is tied okay
is it my turn yet settlement
city with christmas cheer
yeah oh yeah you can't build anything no
just hold all your cards like they're
like you're playing poker well
you know
you need some uh napkins they're over
there no i mean i gotta hold the mic too
so annie's got a broom yeah so hold it
in one hand burrito on one right do you
have anything i got a burrito dude
just more i'm going to play more silent
player you know what i mean i like that
i like that role for you um okay so okay
it's not a [ __ ] rule i'm just doing
it voluntarily you gotta roll first i
can't i can't wheel and deal right now i
have to roll through this yeah
and roll it right here
don't don't lift it oh my god
seven
so you get to move the robber and put it
over your enemies dots
and prevent them from taking any
enjoyment from that plot of land and
also you get to steal a card from them
and then also if you have more than one
cards well you can make fun of it all he
wants if he gives us two dollars
can i do two dollars
yeah make fun of us are you still from
riley riley are you still from real
uh
i mean i guess i'm not really stealing
if i just pick random yeah
nice
[ __ ] can you buy anything i'm gonna kill
myself okay not really sorry i can't say
that you can't say that right now uh i
didn't mean to say that okay it's fine
i mean okay i do need to i want to do
something okay
but i need in but first
i will trade
someone one
one wood and one
i will trade them i will trade them one
wood
for a sheep
okay can i change that offer
i'll take a brick do you have a brick
you have a sheep
no you want a sheep yes
did your breakfast
no
shoot for a brick arrow would have sheep
and
super valuable this game yeah
yeah not really if one ship is worth one
brick
i got a brick this house took forever
give it to me
um yeah i have to wait then okay
sorry just gestured towards the dice
that was good it's like what do you want
okay observe it
yesterday
observed
seven oh no please man
damn this is not
he's seven to seven
honestly we think about what you're
doing 99
that's when you're 69 someone in a
wheelchair who are you selling from
uh i'm gonna steal from candace it's
good why
i wonder why because you stole from me
yeah but it's not and i'd never forget
my people dude you're not even thinking
about my my people go [ __ ] about your
people that's so shitty you're people
that's so shitty
i'm having a cold war with candace
dude this is not
this is not a cold war it seems pretty
cold it's actually true i get it
okay nailed it
six
damn
dude
um someone said yellow hat are you
single
oh my god whoa is missing
mr pebek
all right mr payback
you're not supposed to read every
comment how many mr pitch
will it take to go on a date with
candace
um okay if it was mr pibb original with
the beveled can that would be one case
but if it's mr pip extra
there's no amount too extra for you
are you [ __ ] kidding me riley's gonna
win this game
you know i feel the energy of it i feel
the energy of it you know i couldn't do
it
it's not the money we're getting
send in more money
if you
believe in katana as much as you do and
the
santa
said bunny the santa
so uh who's uh who's winning you think
i think my i think i think riley's
winning but i think i've also only
because i felt his wrath
in war so um maybe i'm just how did it
feel
my people are dying cities are really
good our resources are lacking
we're having a slight famine okay
it's just there's a drought so maybe if
you roll a robber put it on riley's [ __ ]
yeah now it's just i mean there's
nothing else to do i would not i would
not want to offend anyone else to the
table i basically sent troops to your
territory yeah
they're raping and pillaging on that sex
we don't really know just village we
don't really know that also murdering i
think they're gearing up too they're
pillaging their i don't think they're
doing that they might be pillaging but
they're asking for consent
yeah
great well they're at the doors and you
know how you know how like well you know
the city you know and there's boards
like hey
it's like you know
yeah i'm not going to take them on a
date but you know yeah that's like well
because it's like the people servicing
the soldiers are like that's what i'm
thinking you know totally
and they're at the they're right here
think about
jerry bird saying i am we taught did i
am sofa king we taught did so how did
so we todd did am i oh i get it that's
funny we taught this
everyone just thinks you're saying
something oh you're not saying
wow
what a good tactic
yeah that's what i knew it was a joke
yeah i'm actually offended about that
because
um
that's a clever clever trick would you
roll
through
my goes the mustache of a pringles can
not even joking
please hold
continue
would you roll pat
on my pre i think i rolled the can i hit
your jewel
yeah i had an eight on my roll
that was okay thank god i love losing a
couple times ago i got pretty high off
that joint that errol passed around yeah
you know i know you guys are [ __ ]
talk that was a meta joint that's why i
know i'm done that's all i got
pass the dice dies
so uh what do you think about the austin
comedy scene it's got a lot of killers
in it right yeah afforded all right i'm
winning now are you from the old scene
canvas
i'm like somewhere in between
like i i was i existed in the old scene
but i wasn't anyone like i wasn't
you didn't respect them no it's not that
there's some tales from the old scene
from the yonder age there's nothing to
tell i was very like i kept to myself
uh the old keep to yourself trick yeah
sneak right in there i mean i feel like
they're a little snobby and they uh
don't want to associate with the rabble
which is ripe for comedy wait a second
do it oh never mind
so are you gonna buy anything i'm
thinking about it right now hans i don't
need the pressure all right i'm really
struggling yeah we're just asking no i
know
i get that um but uh i need to make a
trade do you guys have guns in ammo
is that yoni
um you're doing it wrong you're doing it
wrong do it like this no like how you
want to do it do it how i want you to do
it
okay guys may i please trade if anyone
has a sheep available
i would really much like to trade for
sheep
please sir do you have a sheep does
anyone have do you have sheep i don't do
you have sheep arrow
and if you do
what yeah what's your problem
my pyramid would be white cloth that's
for two cards
i want three cards okay sure i don't
even care at this point
i won i would prefer two
i would do wood and uh
i'd do one of each of those okay and
then one more of your choosing
really can i just give you the two
i played a win you know what i mean
there you go
three cards i'm too i'm too kind
of a ruler this is why my people will
die
people will die this is like what would
happen if frozen was an actual kingdom
in england or in uh yeah europe for sure
everything's ice
we shall give them ten thousand dollars
and they shall not invade us what what's
funny about the movies like they're tr
there's like ice traders in the movie
like that's how they make their living
is like selling ice
yeah it's like
you could've just done that like you're
just like made up but wait how did they
finish this way that was how did they
wait
for it else again oh well she was just a
little child that she was afraid to use
but also think about this too like how
did they keep the ice cold
because
because obviously they're trading it
which means that there's a need for it
elsewhere but they don't have
refrigerator trucks or anything so you
can't just like take the ice without
melting it can be cold but you can't
make ice
i mean it could be winter but you you
know i get that but there's the water no
i get that but like how do they trade it
like if they just keep it in the
basement and then it slowly melts over
time and you chip away
no i get that but like how do you
transport the ice to the right
no uh sleds but through it
would it last oh yeah they're like a
giant ice cube i just melted it you
gotta insulate it the other places
aren't oh wait you insulated all winter
i'm thinking of a perpetual winter
versus that used to be a thing like you
could buy ice it was like before easy
stupid
okay i don't know what your question is
i don't i think i'm confused they used
they like it's fun too
they just like make fridges like they
would like harvest ice during the winter
like right before spring and then they
would put it all in this cave and then
they'd use that as a fridge
i do know this for sure yeah no i saw a
video on it they do and they also they
also used to make uh for like really
rich people and like kings and stuff
would make like ice cream from like
going to get like wherever they're
storing the ice or like up in the like
top places yeah [ __ ] so it's like yes
that's like a big thing but also yeah
when these people it's like a humble
brag to be like i have a room that's
really cold in my house but also the ice
people
you know the little hooks yeah that's
how you move ice
but they used to deliver the ice to the
they saw it
they use a big saw and they sing while
they do it yeah we are the ice men
we love
frozen ones
okay can i buy now that i tried
me
i still can't trade i can't panic it's a
ponzi
scheme your turn
anyone in crypto
i'm not are you no i can't really not
even a dog i can't yeah i got out of
stocks i mean chris therefore my
boyfriend crystal meth
uh
anyone have brick
you gotta roll right
i've got break
riley let's let's build let's let's make
up for our past uh transgressions
and i'm i will trade i will trade with
you
ah
remember in that show when they like
show the house and like they were like
disappointed oh those are the best ones
and there's there's like one episode
she's ladies just crying she was so
upset
why is it pink
this is really what's hard also how many
cards do you have
you gotta figure it's more than seven
you must you got ten you gotta give up
five
how many cards yeah it's more than seven
you go to heaven
but if it's more than eight then you
gotta get raped it's never too late so i
just give up cards right now or it might
be in my turn
no right now you gotta give up five
cards how many cards do you have
how many cards do you have you have to
just give up half them
errol how many cards it's like
you get to choose
make it quick
make it quick jeez guys
um
do you think that uh
does anyone know any languages
i know
i love language
what is your love language touch
mine is
binoculars
illegal activities
hell yeah dude that's comedians are
boring
pure blood your blood is dirty
to unfast myself
it hurts just suck it all out
more than getting
yeah it's like a tattoo gun
or an anti-tattoo whatever thank you sir
i'm sorry
he just embarrassed you publicly yeah
uh
yes please you have straw
no
okay you promised you already shook
hands i didn't i didn't shake your hand
yes you i didn't shake your hand it was
unknown oh look like elsa's being a
[ __ ]
yeah riley you're being a [ __ ] what
you're elsa
what
i'm uh the snowman though yeah because
you're you're so um quick to react and
um very freezing yeah freezing [ __ ]
you're being with such a little baby
you're a white [ __ ] annoying white
secret powers who is the whitest person
here everyone is so white if you're the
one that's personally not me here raise
your hand that's the only thing it's
definitely right but it's because he's
near the light yeah i know and pat's
just red
yeah
i'm in a good lighting position
and i'm just part of the drapes
what shade of color i am i could be
black
he's doing blackface dude oh my god
you guys can't see it but he's doing
blackface right now
i'm doing implied to blackface no it's
i'm looking this is uh like
schrodinger's black face
i am the tannest one here i just got a
tan actually that's why i can't show you
guys
because it's my tit i'm sorry
like
you're like uh you can look at them but
they can't look at you you look like a
jabberwocky or would it be is it still
is it still blacklist if someone just
like tanned just their face
uh okay but maybe that's just what they
i don't know and it was not malice
behind it would that still be blackface
does anyone have
different situations you have to hear
her out dang
is that anybody
dude errol's got all the stuff what a
great
farmer i got hey earl's in a commune
he's tricking us to join it
i'll do it you have sheep riley
yes you want wait
wheat no
i can't help you
okay i honestly just need some i need i
really need wheat
i can't do i'm gonna bust open these we
need weed i'm gluten
i need
yeah thank you
thanks man
this is not my weed
there you go oh no wheat
oh
nice two bricks
i mean you know no need to put it away
who has the lighter errol
thank god she's i would um
be really grateful if anyone were to are
you done riley have some weeds and yeah
i would trade it's your turn i have weed
i just can't trade handsomely for it you
know i
hosed you so hard earlier i feel
okay can we do it or not yeah i don't
wanna i don't even wanna trade it though
i mean i mean it happened it happened
who wants
wheat or wood
you want this
um
i'd be down to take some wheat
you want wheat for breakfast some wheat
no i would not
i will
i'll take wheat for brick i would like
actually no i'm not sorry i'd like i
take some bread i'm into brick
what about wood for brick
no i'm good things you got the brick or
wood what about do you have wheat
i don't know haunts do i you want wood
no i'm good thanks christmas i'm sorry
i'm not i can't trade right now you want
next i'd like brick you gave it
rock no
what about wheat bricks
what about wood just brick
that's right that's yours
uh
who wants uh wood or wheat or rock
can we just have a holly jolly christmas
for a brick or
two woods can i have one wood four
uh
actually i need two woods okay
okay sorry that's okay
boy i'm just exposing my
cards right there just
did yeah good you're feeling good wait
uh who rolled what tom would you roll
10. okay
[ __ ]
you miss out all the time
yes sir the good lord has damn it why
did i say that i should live her to me
it's okay
it's okay
there's a jewel
it's all those five dollars people are
sitting there this is amazing
for the week
can you argue about something to
entertain us honestly no no i don't
something controversial
uh i need the wheat now
what's something controversial
um
mexican
go for it
mexican just a concept of them
mexicans
do they exist mexicans do they have the
best food
i would say it's pretty good i would say
it's adequate but you don't want it it's
more than it's so great
mexican food is not as spicy as other
things yeah
that's not true though because everyone
does it differently there's so many
different regions of mexican cuisine and
every family does their own thing and
different like like my sister-in-law's
mom like her stuff is a lot always spicy
because that's she's what she's doing
that's what she likes to do and then my
sister-in-law makes like less spicy food
and different versions of that
it's just like it's so good it's just
like goop no it's not were you getting
your chinese or you saw your chinese
food sorry that was already slipped dude
that was my best chinese uh yeah it was
pretty offensive um no where do you get
your mexican food everywhere
everywhere that's popular like where i
play everywhere in every city that i've
been in and damn it you need to go to
mexico it's time for you
i think that mexican food is good but
gotcha is not my favorite
but uh what is your what's your least
favorite food
i was going for your sheep
that was the
reason behind that one at least favorite
food is definitely uh
jewish
jewish
what is jewish food
gefelt fish
and i'm done with my turn done yeah cool
hummus my turn pastrami sandwiches
sixer yeah
sixes
six is hot sixes are high right now
whoever's reds really lighten it up
fixes were always hot
especially
silly so um i think asian food is really
good but maybe i'm biased absolutely but
that's like
that's another one of those things where
it's like you have it and sometimes it's
not great but it's only because the
people who are cooking it aren't making
it great well that's every food i mean
just in general oh like what's your
favorite likes um
asian food like chinese food
that one
no
roll it in the box
oh sorry
all right good
yes
nice uh-huh serves you right riley why
what did you just say that because you
didn't have an eight
was it an eight before yeah i thought it
was a 64. oh how selfless of you
sorry i doubted you okay can i do my
thing now
yeah okay
yeah people are really into what's the
american
he wants us to talk about the armenian
genocide american genocide that's what
that that's what i read mexicans moving
into america is doing but it's
it says was worse than what worse
um
was worse was worse
than what what then the holocaust
numbers-wise i don't think so
and the thing about the germans was they
were like good at it
who's trying to debate these things he's
like you know what's what's the worst
thing in the world it's like why are we
spending time on the inaudible yeah we
should only think about positive things
all the time
wait
wait
i think yeah
oh
if we ever get into a war with our media
and then if i'm building stuff i have to
trade it in right
yeah yeah light it up
we should be like you guys are a bunch
of armenians
armenia is a country
you know what you mean in the piles dude
yeah
that's gay no that's super cool
what kind of board games
like
boredom uh hungry hippos
yeah does it have to be completely flat
you can't build there
so built here you can't build here
oh why just be it be a warrior who's
going to be a one away this is
that now because of the
brown settlement to its
oh because of this
okay
no canned duo
you're screwed i can go here right yes
yes
i don't want to go there though
you don't have to follow the original
road you built yourself you could divert
what
really yeah you could build another
route oh my god okay fine
oh no no no no i mean like you could
build like the road doesn't have to keep
fault you could just like go like you
could put a road here
oh
oh
all right all right all right
so like it doesn't have to follow
but i can't go i can't do that though
because it doesn't
all the way over here and build that but
that's
good come all the way over here
police officers good weed very this is
nice adl supported comedy
now i want to put my settlement do i i
could just do a road here yeah you have
to put another road
okay
i can't put a house there right
and then
pat can i just put
a house anywhere
no the house needs to be at the end of
the two section road yeah we've only
seen red do that
and i've done that in the over here but
yeah
that's how it has to look so i would
have one more road and then my house
thank you yeah okay
do you want some water in canvas um yes
that would be great thank you
here candace can just have some fun
why don't i get
you a cup of water
why do i feel so dumb right now okay
i'm retreating back into this can you
see what he's doing over there let's run
that's exactly what then i'm gonna go
see what he's doing over there yeah it
looks like he's poisoning the water
supply
at this
game all right you guys are gonna leave
well hydrated
so did you guys really think that i was
gonna poison one of you
that would have been cool
with love poison
i'm gonna poison you with love because i
have to have two roads between houses
yeah but you could go
here
and then save this for a settlement
okay
i already did a settlement and then i
was told i can't do a settlement
yeah you can't
okay
you can't do it here
you can do it here though that's where i
had one earlier
no you didn't you had it here no and
then i had it here though okay then no
you didn't you had two reasons
settlement
a skunk sat on the stump and the stump
thunk the skunk stunk but the skunk
thunk the stump stunk
two dollars more if anyone can get it
the first time reading it
that's a fun little game yeah i'm
finally done with this trick you enjoyed
that
yeah
i mean if you paid five dollars i feel
obligated to read it no i like how you
just ran right in i was trying to figure
it out as i went and you i it was a
trust exercise really beautiful
yeah i mean it's a tongue twister
whipped right through it
no i made a couple mistakes
you just gotta turn off your brain and
just
read it like you're in school
at school
son
so how about
banana phone tonight what about that
great job by candace medina
it was a real hoot i mean just a hoot
watching youtube up there was like
it was fun i felt like i had sisters if
anyone doesn't have sisters you know
what i mean i wouldn't be a great show
to go to heather like we should really
mean i wanted to do something with her
like a project she did my little show
too before that at six oh yeah yeah just
putting in the hours yeah grinding like
the real comments
champion she's grinding she's great and
she's just got like
she's just like naturally funny and it's
like really fun to just like play off
that and be silly and like i don't know
tonight was really fun i had a lot of
good a good time today
so this one yeah i think we both pull
off this like
really
perfect balance of like lovable and kind
of like hateable and [ __ ] like it's
a trifecta whoa whoa no no no just hear
me out of that no i mean sex is a large
part of uh humanity there's something
you just don't need to say though no i
mean like think of it as like a trap no
i'm not trying to gross anyone now she
didn't talk about it i mean it's not
like that she's like no no i get what
you guys are saying but um
yeah that's our friend
i'm not if you're implying i'm trying to
say i'm trying to i don't think that's
not what i'm saying i know what you're
saying but like i said what you're
saying that's not what i'm saying either
it's just like candace isn't gonna date
you
what is
what in god's country what in god's
country everyone is stable
he's a chill um and i stopped smoking
country you mean texas am i right folks
i'm saying that there was you love texas
donate 12
hans
she is single
um beautiful girl in the green code are
you single
i am uh
i am existing i don't know
that's a yes
i'm existing
green girl is that riley or is that uh
candace
um i'm
actually you could be the green girl no
i'm not
gonna clarify
yeah that's a good point
because
uh it's in my turn should we it's mr pip
award should we turn that
uh
it's still riley's turn
this game takes ages
what is this a weird form of like not an
exclusive
this is like conversation absolutely
plus background noise i'm starting to
think that i might be a little um
i might be a little bit adhd i think
uh definitely it could also be just a
weird thing but i feel like we're also
blasted
i've been high this whole time yeah this
whole time dude
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point like way high
but uh
i'm having a good time i think it's just
like fun we got a brick in the crowd
we're just talking we're just watching
we're just uh talking to each other oh
you're still on that oh brick and you
find folks got a brick out there
oh my gosh all right you guys are too
much fun you guys are a hoot in this
whole comment section just a good time
and everyone's just having a [ __ ]
hoot and hollering shoes
yeah but it's all right oh my goodness
who knew
do you think that um
yes the awesome comedy scene is going to
be the future of comedy
for years to come
any future is here bro
i mean we have joe rogan
own him we have others
but i have to use it now
i'll get a rock
okay
this is the best best christmas ever
this honestly is a great christmas this
is a good this is a good
christmas lord i'll run out okay so
let's be interesting guys for the camera
why don't you guys why don't you do your
like improv exercise that you're doing
earlier
this probably doesn't make any sense
okay so there's a binocular and riley is
a pirate that just found some booty and
he's super excited about this level
treasure
hey matey
gold doubloons
gold doubloons
there's so many words for gold it's like
dude i don't think the balloons is one
of them doubloons you guys are out of
your freaking mind what is the balloons
gold a gold doubloon
i've never heard that before
is that is it a bunch of gold doubloons
polling all nighters 19 was this [ __ ]
it is a
[ __ ] i have two shoes i don't give a
[ __ ] it's friendly
fun
just
eating it up and that's a number for me
this is who this guy is right yeah you
can't get it i can't nope
how do i get them off you're gonna roll
a seven or eight one eight use a
development card to get a knight
got it
so candace what do you think about
uh
the whole
uh you think riley should like do more
comedy or do you think you should keep
being sad
i think he's doing both really well
thank you
uh did he do a good job tonight at the
banana phone
yeah
yeah
i think so i think everyone did a good
job
i think you could
interpret it that way everyone did riley
behave himself with the banana phone
riley and his silly jokes i know how he
got sometimes
we hate him too
we thank you for dealing with him but uh
we're gonna get him looked at my dad uh
bill clinton
no listen here
i'll listen here riley i did not i can't
do it i don't have sexual relations with
that woman
rally four
um i did
and
not
got a bunch of [ __ ] altered
you know
can you try it
oh yeah i can just trade guys hey you
guys um
i'm looking for
right now i'm sitting on uh what i'm
looking for is that that brick you know
what i'm gonna hook you up break you
gotta break you open that last one you
just okay
before what are you looking for your
choice what are yours that you are nice
okay um i truly what i'm looking for
currently i would say would be
talking about a wheat right now but or
yeah
rock would be great rock i can do
okay
amazing
okay uh do you want that again i could
trade you play that same no no no this
guy's from minnesota he loves uh he
loves women that wear big coats yeah so
you want to do an improv exercise so if
you're from florida
your fetish is flip-flops and
maybe it's maybe your fetish is flip
flops if you're from like i do sheep for
a wood puerto rico no somewhere really
colder i have played because you don't
actually
so it would be it would be a flip flop
you had a brick to give the noise so
true you're like damn you're having warm
sex yeah then there's thinking about
feet
they're just frigid well i'm trying to
think if i'm if i even
dreaming of warm tones
um that's what's your kink
like say the only thing would be rock
what's your cake a warm fireplace rock
rock
for brick to rock
yeah okay no one rock
a glass of milk and cookies
anyone got wood
hood
you know i really watched my capacity
yeah i would
but i don't have
wood really
hans you only get a wood for what
[ __ ] you want
sheep
two wood i'll give you sheep
i don't have two but one would i'll give
you a sheep
i'm good thank you god bless
you any wood
um i just i'm i've reached my trading
capacity this morning holy [ __ ] it's
been your time this whole turn this
whole time well i'm you guys didn't open
up for trading so i went to trade
okay let's do an improv exercise where
we're all on a hot air balloon and
who's who's driving who's in charge oh
the murderer errol is trying to pop the
balloon and we're all trying to stop him
is he also in uh is this a team building
exercise is it in the i think it might
be ultimately maybe yeah
like getting used to some uh intergroup
turmoil's point
what does the balloon really mean to you
i'm into it
eight
i don't why why
yeah
the guy first guy who did a hot air
balloon must have been like whoa
imagine just coming up with that i guess
it's just it'd be scary as [ __ ]
yeah
like well i think what i'm gonna do is
i'm just gonna fill this up with the
right amount and then at some point it's
gonna lift in the air and then actually
i don't actually know what the [ __ ]
gonna happen after that part here we go
that's some ballsy [ __ ] man people
usually just gonna be in the air people
that's gonna heat this thing yeah how
big does it have to be yeah like that's
what that was their people's like going
to show more blankets together
yeah that's their elon musk
movement was the guy in the booth
is it repetitive he just rockets yes
i'm just and tesla sorry no it's okay no
i finally had a breakthrough
has not yet been popped
yeah you stop
playing with the shears near the ropes
like that it's making me nervous hey
arrow um
right why don't you just come down and
chill dude
wait there's two stories to this you're
right my bad
yeah
we saved the hot air balloon
yeah okay wow that was
in the end we were the hot air balloons
wild they're all balloons yeah
and we can't stop ourselves from filling
up with hot air
uh you want to go your words my man
i'm good i'm i i can't
so riley's turning me
yeah it'll be really soon
yes
sure i'm at the point where i think
chugging water is funny so
yeah
i love the sound of chugging water
honestly it is a pretty cool like you
get quenched even if you're not you feel
yeah yeah you're like [ __ ] that's some
hydration
it's good clean fun that's good that is
good clean fun wet you're done wet clean
fun
wco
five
nice time come on come on come on baby
come on baby
nope
okay and i need your help who has sheep
and once oh yeah
oh
but i'm gonna charge you yeah
three cards dude sheeps are like big
deal
i know you want um because you gotta get
a settlement i have a sheep i do
what do you want to eat i want wood
wood give me wood
damn he slipped in
nice
that's nice
you got too greedy i know i know
um
christmas time
for a word
red looks solid like a clear winner
really i know but i know the guy to my
right is just doing well like just lots
more exchanges than i can even dream of
not first place i know you're doing good
it's the the the gap between where i
oh
am
don't
i don't think that's a good idea
sevens oh no we're still we know i don't
think anyone's are really into sevens on
this game seven's a good number though
yeah
it's the rearranged time
just don't [ __ ] me bro you know what i
mean
i just don't [ __ ] me that's something
yeah i've already done that in fact
right and i'm trying
i just i just think that's really nice
that's honestly not chill pat but that's
chill i think it's a good move uh that
is uh
under guidelines katan guidelines uh 51b
that is not chill yeah
roger that we're gonna have to pull you
over for being unchilled
i've got a uh passenger looks to be not
very chill
his sheep are out of control
the guy over seems
a [ __ ] loser
i'm gonna bring it down to the station
okay
and my turn is done
now what are those cards you've been
saying
you're able to buy a development card
it's on your it's the bottom item on the
menu copy that
yeah and i can just this is the
development card it gives you like
different things to do like hans played
one that lets them take two of any
resources
got it okay my turn
oh whammy's no whammies no emmys
wow okay that's pretty good no that's
good for me yeah you said no emmys
no way
would you get eight it's a whammy
you're old it's like a classic guy
tv a game show
it was like a little buddy or like a
little guy would go whatever around yeah
it's kind of like they'd spin and you
don't want to get the whammies and they
wait wait for it so they always go no
enemies no i mean
i missed the time of the the american
game show
the time of the game show game show
network was
i don't i haven't watched tv in a long
time but i used to love jeff that was a
lot have you seen the guy that timed it
he went on yeah yeah yeah the
documentary
what
did you know that the the pun is the
highest form of art in punjabi
the uh
noise
the the guru
he's a big fan
to develo a card oh yeah i don't know i
know i'm just the ruler has the most
puns
yes she's the master you had just built
them placed two new roads dude these
cards are great you gotta use the next
check and also don't tell people okay
um that's awesome die i know you're done
pass me this that's the guy girl
that's it thank you [ __ ] dude you can do
something else you want to do something
else i feel like okay
i don't i don't think i can you're right
you're right i don't have wood unless
anyone wants to trade me for what anyone
got wood
no
for what
i got a lot of stuff that's not wood
sheep
i'll give you a cheaper wood
noise noise noise noise can i'm gonna
play
we got wood when we got some [ __ ]
brickie because we put in a road
together my friends
it
right there
awesome
all right and um
that's just the flow are you ready
eight
oops oh geez that scared them
whoa
can i just try something
so i'm gonna buy a couple
whoa it's supposed to be like a word of
panic
but then when you say it's just like
whoa man
i looked it up in my word of panic books
what is that a word word of panic
where does that come
like wowzers i don't know if you guys
don't know this fun fact but that's a
word of pain
it's a bird of prey
that's a bird panic sure where to panic
and i get in a panic
yep okay that tracks whoa what the [ __ ]
is going on here wild whoa
i think i hit it that's definitely not
where i was no
no i was on the five
honestly
the huns beat the romans right
yep
sorry candace
what
where i was roasting i was resting you
pretty hard there what'd you say
it's gonna be wild looking back on this
for both of us it's what i was gonna i
mean i could all agree on apparently
hans is acting or he really just does
know the whole thing the whole time i'm
not sure what do you think
certain feel he's in
good power good i don't know
i don't know if i can handle this
you're doing great
are you done
dude look how clear this is look how
freaking clear this is you can see the
feeling
the detail
is
this is it's immaculate
through these binoculars
wow now i see why people spend a lot of
money on these
yeah it's a nice piece of equipment you
should try it during the daytime when
you're not inside
i honestly i um i read online that's not
good for your eye so i only do it
indoors
you can never go back if you use a whole
bunch of mushrooms and just go look at
[ __ ] through binoculars that's probably
a really [ __ ] good time are you done
you're stumbling upon some really uh
yeah i think eyes
here hd
six six
crazy hd
yeah
that's what tv was always trying to
replicate it feels like hd do you guys
remember when yeah video in real life
he's trying to make it feel like real
life yeah but do you remember yeah when
that was like
the original like hd look like [ __ ]
just realized
what it is now yeah we put plasma in the
screen
i think i don't know if it was what it
looked like i realized i feel like it
was the way that like you're you're
perceiving it for the first time maybe
you know yeah
in real life
i deserve that
what if you didn't would you smack me
dude snacking
nobody is a violent man
you have warrants
i'll probably have outstanding parking
tickets so i can't go back to whoa
i know hey jeez the government is
watching this
it's true
you can get every minute it's also true
that one time i bought weed
nice dude what a great story that's good
um
i think it's honestly not good dots are
connected is it illegal to buy weight
in texas it is
i'll play this guy
oh i'm just gonna use those two folks
dude this is the biggest holiday banger
what about mariah carey
no this is this is called this is it
what about this this is a silent night
and uh and little drama boy those in
fifth grade i played the partridge in
the pear tree because it was a play that
got to involve all the kids in the
school i was the partridge in the pear
tree and during rehearsal
i passed out oh [ __ ] classic cartridge
what happened
how did it go from the inside are you
allergic do you remember anything
that was good
i just think the suit wasn't letting my
young pale skin breathe
oh wow yeah suit was too tight yeah plus
i was on the highest elevation that i
had to be there
stairwell cartridge
wow
yeah too much
yeah i asked you right out and then what
do you remember getting me an iv and all
that
you were the partridge
oh it's my turn or
your turn
my turn maybe
i played a partridge in a play once uh
no i'm pretty sure
that's the rule if they're different
i think it's the apartment
oh what was it what did you guys roll oh
eight eight
oh
my god
use your words man
that's my mic
me riley
oh age good number
oh
me rock anyone got any wheat
no
wheat
really
truly
riley
really no wheat
no weed to give this christmas
holy [ __ ] like really
i feel like you're like sex tree right
now
what if this was like they had like a
six people and sellers like a town he's
like you got a new wii
oh man
i need some sheet oh okay then you [ __ ]
me i'm done i'm done
wonderful
hell yeah damn damn
yeah we got [ __ ] by riley or someone
eats
oh i got sheep that is the ghost of
christmas pass
pale is the ghost i'm the ghost of
christmas white um so does uh
does anyone have sheep
oh yeah
okay oh yeah can i please get a sheep i
got it i can get you a rocker but you
got any wheat it's always a white
crystal find me some wheat come on dog
really you don't have any wheat
okay dog okay [ __ ] it just whatever you
got what would you prefer i don't know
rocker brick what do you want
do you want rocker break
you
okay i'll take a brick or rock i'll take
a rock that's actually pretty good okay
that's the one i haven't gotten can i
have some mouth too or no
um so anyways i'm going to build a quick
little city boy oh man i'm a sante boy
is it sam oh
[ __ ]
okay
i take it back i'm not doing that i'm
done my turn is over now why would you
not do that
because um i uh i miscalculated
yeah
katan it'd be like that
you don't have um say um
or you're not gonna speak
i thought i was about to come up i think
it's a power move to say um it was a big
waste of everyone's time so it's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna power move this well
i just felt like he was gonna do
something but then it is he thought it
was like talking but it's like just
you're just doing so you don't need to
you know like i am going to do something
yeah and i was about to do something and
then i thought about it
wow
that's a little bit odd
your beta yeah
cool that makes sense i'm actually an
omega man
anyone have brick
or sheep yep wait i got sheep and you
need everything do you have wheat i have
wood rock
or brick
i'll take a wood
what do you want rick okay
after i make deals with riley i feel
like
i don't know
the exchange boost
i'll think about it
oh my god riley why would you do that
riley
your turn bro
now let's see how can i
[ __ ]
squish you
wow
i feel like they have a lot more
strategy than you do in general um i
wouldn't say necessarily i'm starting to
get the hang of it so i did a little
strategy involved i'm starting to get
there
that was another word of panic that was
the grinch
yeah we just traded that wood back and
forth man you know what i think
that wood is coping though you want this
wood
yeah
yeah i need wheat
i need wheat and i'll have training for
the wood though
wait would you roll oh
or wheat for a rock
um
god damn it please i really need this
this looks delicious they're pretty good
are they seasonal
can you build in between two roads thank
you i don't think so
i don't think so
can i build an old settlement
between two roads
yes really
and settlements blew up
the road main jersey community was like
the two rivers and about a settlement at
that moment
mr pitt wants to know hans if he donates
will you give it to candace for
how do christmas uh
[ __ ] yeah it's
like a microphone it's called microphone
but like my phone is way smaller than
this
okay
so like it's not even like that small
i can get away i guess
it's like microwave i might as well get
away
okay go ahead i'm done
christmas it's not bad
seven [ __ ] ate it
wow
wow
okay
i'm not doing that good
you're not doing that well hans
thank you
i ain't doing that good
do you think they still like
like after jesus got crucified were they
like
all right so should we stop christmas
yeah that's a good point yikes
beginning to look a lot like christmas
that was so fun i don't know
celebrate christmas
that's my least favorite holiday song
originally jesus had to go off and die
like an idiot
jesus ruined christmas
anyone got any weed
yet
anyway no okay any would you roll
anywhere
eight was rolled
yeah
this is not going i need [ __ ] is this
how it always goes at the end
look it's scarce okay
okay trading these four
superheroes they're like marvel
superheroes like noah
jesus
like
yeah
other jews what about the greek gods
oh but no like moses was just like a
normal dude
like that one guy who like
i think in the bible he lives to be
hundreds of years old yeah there's like
[ __ ] oh really
i only have one of those special powers
done
was it him was it him that's all the
burning bush too and like the
but he was a normal dude at first right
yeah and then and then god or was he
like a demigod because there's only one
son of god
right yeah i never thought about it like
that that's a good point
definitely yeah
thank you
i've been doing my research
[ __ ] but uh
yes what are some other powerful jews
name your top five
favorite most powerful
if you had a jew power what would it be
oh no we're good this is getting uh
the power of
suspicion
the power of miserliness
trying to see if i can ban people from
here
are you gonna ban
mr pibb
damn i'm sorry damn he's getting so many
[ __ ] hey shout out to him
but these are in timeout hey sorry hey
uh sorry shout out to mr pip extra dude
i see what you out there doing i'm
really happy and proud of you should i
add him as a moderator
is that too much power i will
give you this address
damn i mean mr pibb like your wrongs
or write it
you need to write your wrongs
he's just saying the worst thing is
possible are you is it your turn riley
wait
please
is it my turn
all right you better not build a
settlement there
do you have enough i ain't saying
nothing
do you have enough riley before um do
you have i'll trade you some bread for
wood what did you roll what'd you roll
i'll change your brick for what okay
here where
here wait i'll give you a break
okay
wow okay
god damn it this is gonna be fun
yes bummer dude the trail is mine full
steam ahead gentlemen you have enough
for a settlement your defense is gonna
get along this road as well
if you get longest road i'm gonna get
longest road
why would you build roads this way and
this way are you out of your mind me
no riley no
because
there's plenty of land to be
conquered
oh my god how can i lose to such idiotic
play
that's god's will baby it's god's plan
this is that it happened able to go
starfish yeah we were just like i don't
know annoyingly
they're like i'll go here now whatever
no that's great this place is cool i
guess
we're just gonna cough on everyone
and uh let's go in the winter time so
that we have a lot of snow to play with
i'm stressed out
yeah that hits the christmas spot
that tickles that like christmas holiday
itch
that jingle bell and you're ringing in
your ear
okay i'm ready
santa claus strap scratching your nose
jack frost
crust punching you in the face
nice cold punch
why did you
jack frost look like it happened i know
i can't this is so hard i'm sorry it's
more dots this way
unless you need wheat
this
that's like sexual assault
okay i mean you kind of like wait so
maybe you should about that that's what
i want okay don't stop don't don't
involve jack
frost are you done yes i was finally
done riley
do you have enough for a settlement
let's see
i don't want to miss the white means
nowhere
yes joel osteen
six
there nice
anyone uh any of your fellow travelers
have sent any wheat no no
don't try it you have to say no nope
please
not
give you whatever you want
next turn
do not give the wheat i'll give you
anything you want come on now come on
now jensen jackals
don't trade with it
he's an idiot kidding what say the right
things
what do you got for it maybe i'm
purposely saying
uh i got some rocks i got heavy-duty
rocks i'll give you
two rocks
if you don't trade them i'll give you
three rocks
for wheat
i'll give you
i'll give you two three rocks and a
brick hey
era listen to me i'll give you two rocks
and a wood
you have two cards you don't need it
don't be nice
be nice to me
being mean to riley is being nice to me
that is your prize for being a loyal
trader with riley corporation
don't do it thank you to ours don't give
in you're talking is this we're talking
one wood what am i looking at two rocks
in the woods a weed or a sheep i'll take
i'll take uh you can have all that
but you don't have a weight
you have a sheep
you need a wheat i say sheep
oh you're very far from us no no no he
said wheat or sheep you don't have a
wheat either
no i don't
if you get sheep
you guys want sheep yeah i'll take uh
for a week
oh give me a sheep or a wheat
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good
trick i can give you more give me i can
give you more i can give you that plus
brick
do it take it take it take whatever hans
is getting in here
and a wood
you're gonna use sweet four cards if you
don't trade with them this time dude
take that i know but i don't want that
can you it doesn't matter it's as if
it's the same thing but better i had i
can do everything you can do plus a
break next she says
yeah yeah give me this too no but i
can't do it
you got to wait no we got to trust them
why no i'm not going to try i mean
i trust you too i'll give you all this
if you don't trade with riley right now
no dude trey i would just go back to
where i mean
this is wild
about loyalty i mean you know what
happened the first round when riley uh
i'll tell you this blocked my play
so that that's we built a beef and that
you that should have never happened
wait actually i'm not gonna do it okay
no actually i will haunt's backed out
like usual
this is this is just ruby's not a good
businessman
no i'll do it backs out i'll do it dude
you gotta make it happen right now i
know i'm gonna trust you on this but if
this is gonna be really painful
then don't set yourself up okay i
promise because i really don't can give
it to him that's crazy he promised you a
lot of crazy yeah i promised you a lot
of things
i would rather have the good will of
candace medina on my side while i'm up
at banana phone next week
getting roasted and toasted
he's taking
the [ __ ] over riley which is the thing
in the world
yeah
are you done
all right fine
is this still my turn wow what action
yeah all right i'm gonna play my night
card high drama
candace
[ __ ]
if you want to play
his
allies dad like lily hans
very natural
that's more powerful
shut the [ __ ] up at the same time
at this very moment my army is entering
your walls
yeah it's fine dude i'm breaking yours
my people will die it's fine they don't
will not die they won't suffer
i will see to it myself
every last one of your kinsmen
uh we'll keep it here
uh
all right this is not good three rocks
per sheet
it you got a sweet from her
yeah that's what i'm saying is like that
is the most isn't that so [ __ ] epic
because it it basically avoids our thing
i know because but by not just by chance
how [ __ ] is that yeah
wow it's almost wow riley are you done
i've had my fill
[ __ ] this is not good oh [ __ ]
i'm so upset right now it is like
literally
and you get no he doesn't get longest
road yet
not yet
oh my god
what a game i'm really upset right now
i'm not gonna lie about that
oh mr pip's back on
oh he's
being racist
yeah that's this kind of thing
yeah what are you gonna do
um
i guess i could do that but do i really
need a road that bad
okay
so what did you want candace
it would be really helpful to me
yeah personally you need a safe space
i'll give you i'll give you sheep right
with her
um
you can work for me you want sheep
i'll give you a sheep i would prefer
wheat
i can give you one week
whoa dude now honda's
fully weeded position where he's able to
how much is crazy um
you choose
wow
see what happens this was the only one
of those
oh my gosh
wait how many cars do you have oh
i don't want to give you too many
because you might get seven
goody goody i have seven
that's good i mean you think that's good
or do you think you want me to hold on
to the sheep and break and give it to
you next turn
um oh double down the trust this is a
swindle i'm gonna say that
i mean i just hope you don't get too
many cards
now that's death this is like this is a
go you know what i mean we established
trust i'm gonna double down on eight and
we have a common enemy now yeah
ah
we were getting [ __ ] over by so that
robber dark
my lord has
just begun mr pibb extra can roast
everyone from kt
like preschoolers
preschoolers would roast this [ __ ] out
of me uh i've eight sheep
they're preschool
they're unschooled
but they're in school but they're
preschool right you know where they're
going well they just know where they're
going but they're not built through an
opponent's settlement
oh i can't believe you use that knife
that's crazy that totally [ __ ] it up
for me
if you pretend
you like
pretend it's before tending yeah you
pretend i'm attending because it takes
pretend presents to pretend
content
me too i contest that's lovely i'm
pretending i'm in a tent
oh yeah i can tend to that well you're
an intent you're always attentive i'm
not well i blood tend
for bartenders
i didn't hear the question yeah
would you classify yourself as attempted
yeah
you're welcome everybody
sanders here
oh my god i can't believe it oh wow hans
is having a great game it seems oh
whenever you're ready no restaurant
because you're going you're at this
you're like obviously you intend to
build a settlement over there oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold up
check it
check it i have this [ __ ] thing i've
been sitting on
and that makes me build two [ __ ]
roads just like friends
wow that's a good one good play thank
you good play like
being community leaders
can you pass me the
the shoes
being immunity leaders with their
vaccination status
i'm almost ready to get the booster
before i come home 11.
a johnson and johnson again
that is such a [ __ ]
dude everyone was making fun of me for
getting moderna but moderna is the best
pfizer is not as good people thought
pfizer was the best in the beginning
yeah it's true but moderna
um so let me think i need to make a
trade
what's been happening with the pfizers
the pfizers are good but they're not as
good there's a graph
i saw what graph
figures
pick
11 was just rolled dudes i advise you
not to get them okay
i need to trade for wood
hit the bricks honey we got we i got one
in
the books i'm glad you're doing well
matt candice i'm not doing well i'm
doing fine but i gave you all that [ __ ]
yeah i know you're basically i know you
really helped you really just set it a
lifeline
maybe at the next turn can i get some uh
who has wood that they would be able to
sell i do okay
um
how dare you sir
that is my lady and i shall only be the
one to give her wood
i will trade you
um
a
sheep for
two wood
one wood
two wood no i don't need i don't need
any more sheep okay what do you need wow
uh i would take
you have clay or brick rather i can give
you a brick two
i can give you one whoa
uh
someone thought we were on adderall
they thought we were on adderall
yeah
i love adam
earl's blinking is so slow
i've never
done adderall i don't even know what the
effects are supposed to be besides i see
people just could go to work on it it
would turn you into a
corporation you're a machine dude it's
pretty great it's pretty fun
sounds exactly what i'm going away it's
honestly the best draw i don't take it
anymore but it's like limitless you're
into it yeah yeah for some people it's
good it's like it literally god damn you
guys are just coming in from all sides
well you start at like a negative four
that's true yeah that's actually kind of
annoying candace and now i'm at a
negative three i'll just wait hans is a
little annoyed now
i don't need a shape
thank you though it looks so good
quickly he turns into a little right
like a transformer
hand alliance do you guys have an
alliance just i'm just checking i just
want to write my diary
towards each other okay
seven i had that with everyone i thought
right what do you know what i mean you
have you do have this dark energy about
yeah whoa
for real though no that's fair see how
it's like it's still it's benefiting you
that's great yeah oh nice whip around
there
someone's got to do it it's still an
energy i love dark chocolate it's my
secret there's some chocolate over there
i brought snacks too if you guys are
interested in that it's like halfway
there
riley are you really still are you
really still doing this
patty what's the uh
present your cards
no that was a seven that got rolled
because i have more than seven cards i
had to get rid of my empire was growing
so i had eleven so i had to get rid of
five
yeah won anyone have a rock i don't
nope
nice
sheep
what you got
yes
what you've aligned yourself with the
darkness
i cannot follow you're not allowed to
trade with me unless you have a mask on
what the hell
that was going to be a beautiful city
five
reroll
fiverr
can i have another uh brownie riddle
that's why oh
gave you the bag thank you i don't know
where it is though damn it
okay wait what was
five oh my god this is not going well
this is truly just not my game i'm not
getting any numbers
riley i don't know where i put it it
might be up there no
i don't think it's by me
i don't have any weight what about what
what
the brittle the brownie bread i don't
have any wood either
what about wood two wood for one shape
or two sheets
uh i can do i can do you shoot
two shoot for two wood oh you have sushi
what about brick for wood yeah these are
two but i need one sugar
they're apparently
not bad for you
raise the back and they try to convince
you slapping the bag
12.
no come on guys no one is rolling good
numbers
mr pibb really knows how to creep out
the person he's into
you
we gave you three chances
damn dude i have so many i have such a
fan and mr pip extra
also it's not how you spell my name so
it's [ __ ] rude
300 seconds of silence from mr pitt
extra yeah yeah maybe we pour one for mr
pibb extra
yeah give us some money if you all right
we actually need some money for the
memorial for mr pibbxtra so if you don't
mind donating a few dollars
let's start a gofundme for mr we're
trying to build a mausoleum so really
anything helps but mostly big bills
is there is is there any is there any
wheat floating out there
oh i'm winning
roads
nope
one two three four five
is that so good
who's white oh white's tied with me oh
[ __ ]
oh man i think pat's the silent [ __ ]
killer over here i'm waiting what are
vps
again victory points
vagina
vagina
makes sense you never heard of vaginal
pooping
no
uh
western culture
it's the new thing on google
uh it's the new uh
lip
lip enhancing
does anyone have any wheat for sale oh
for a 12 no
roll better [ __ ]
uh
wow i shall call you a friend
you guys are really into those
development cards
about that life
getting a personality in this game
whoa okay
yikes
that's a straight eight dude and eights
are good for me
um
honestly not
straight up hey
yo
okay
anyone got a
brick
four
do you have what i'll trade you a wood
for bird
if i had a brick i would trade a wood
oh wait i won't treat for good
sorry i'll trade you sh
i need a brick
oh it's not my turn okay you can only
trade sheep
i i have
or uh i could do a rock a wheat
no way dude can i have a little dude
give us some chocolate yeah
no no nothing oh sorry
i got a brick it's a little bit it's not
going to hurt puns actually
yeah what do you have
um sheep
i'm good thank you
it's fine
um
i'm shutting her down then
flamer can your dog do a flip arrow you
know you got to ask her that
[ __ ] what is it
nine yeah that's helpful it's your worst
nightmare
you're really getting into this darn
hideous character
darth riley character
it's all in the
gut
does anyone have a wheat i can trade
anyone a weed i can train
i can give you um
sheep
or brick
nope
okay
nope
oh my god
you got the longest row
is that it candace one two three four
five six you had it this whole time
wow
congratulations uh i just would really
just love to thank everyone at the table
for really introducing me
through this game walking me through
some great strategy learning a little
bit um you know i was wondering if you
could lose it at any time do you feel
like i want more power if someone builds
a
lot
why would you even guys just get me
excited about this [ __ ] dude that's
[ __ ] up i was so
individual it's like a ufc
just keep it yeah what can i do with it
nothing
you have two you're closer to winning
you you have six points now you are at
four now you have six
trades you shoot for it
all right now what are we playing two
twenty ten twenty way to twenty that was
sweet
uh okay
that'd be sweet i don't think that's
physically bad
i didn't even say i was done but okay
sure wait i didn't get the knife from my
last turn hey why are you so you're
rolling let me repack no no if you
missed your turn it's too bad what
that's what they told me they made me
yeah that's technically the rule totally
allowed to do that oh my god
you guys are lying too much i like how
the dog can just go outside whenever it
wants it's so cool
it has a door yeah
it's like it's no skin off my back
you just seem like locking up
i love how poo poo just still in the
same spot in the couch
like [ __ ]
he hasn't even discovered the hatch yet
he goes up to the hill he probably like
gets smacked by it oh she couldn't get
through that
she's not like gonna just go she'd have
to body slam it with her head
that is the most like uh
old-fashioned door
wooden door
uh like bolted
it's just like a little part it's
something you can buy
and you put in your sliding door
all right
or maybe build a rustic feel i think you
made it can i repeat this chocolate yeah
it's carols can we use chocolate oh yeah
is this peppermint park are you done
candace
uh it wasn't my charity rolled
it's riley's turn he took over he didn't
have about my turn in this place i said
oh yeah i remember are you kidding me
ah good times
chris young's been here the whole time
there's been some long i don't know
rollers that's why you have wheat that's
cool
yeah it makes sense it's just like i've
never been on this side of it
been since my porn days two bricks
you in them are you
in
you were just the actor you didn't
actually [ __ ] the girl
i was the guy on youtube i was the guy
that you were just they when they zoomed
up to the like thing [ __ ] i was just
they're doing it i gotta leave now
that would have been so clutch
what are you talking about what are you
talking about that probably i have a
port if you have a port you can trade in
whatever it says
oh yeah you can trade two rock in for
any one of anything really yeah
bro rules are so cool no one told me
that this whole time
kind of skipped over it there's a lot
that we did tell you
that's a really good point but at the
same time that would have been really
funny we haven't been playing the same
game
wait i'm not blaming it you can't do it
yet yeah i realized that
are you done riley i'm with you but i
haven't done anything
i didn't know you could do the porch i
just had yes
12 oh my goodness
i think that was a mistake
did you build around a 12 and why are
you profiting from it
um anyone have a wheat that would want
brick or sheep
wheat
i need a wheat or two woods
hey you get it [ __ ] 12 that's funny [ __ ]
12 seriously
all 12's are bastards atabs
you uh you have wheat
arrow
yeah i got a wheat do you want sheep or
what brick
i don't want to trade what about wood do
you have wood
yeah i got wood
i can i can promise you
the christmas playlist
that's how i feel i need wood or wheat
it's lincoln park that's a natural
transition
it's basically the same thing
just angry white
teenagers i'm honestly so upset right
now because i think i could have played
something and it was oh wait no i would
have been able to do anything i feel
like that's pretty much the whole game
one
this is lincoln park i want a good
christmas
i want lots of presents and my
girlfriend is so mean
i hate my girlfriend
i want christmas presents for
my girlfriend
dude crushed it
that's my licking party you've literally
only been making hits
ten
i was very excited about that
now i get a wii
it's a lot of wheat for brown
brown town that's what i call mine
welcome to brown town
taking the downtown yeah we do only anal
sex here
grab a doritos in a mountain
city
we're anabot we're anal about everything
even anal
life is so sad
is it legal if i sorry riley if i can i
build one two roads there
sure you can try yeah i think you can
okay
so i'll
oh then all the good things must be
happening now right i'm prolonging the
game oh it was
oh okay never mind i thought you were
you were around with a good job yeah i'm
blocking riley nice
yeah right there dude
that's such a useless road too besides
for that purpose yeah just the [ __ ] with
you patty
yeah bro because you can't build
anything over here no
i actually haven't built it
this way i pulled the card
build it this way the card
that way to help you dude build it this
way that way you can compete with you
and you can build a settlement already
listen he has a track record of smashing
your roads right here you can't build a
settlement over here so he already put
it down you can't you can pick it back
up at the same
it's illegal it's touch move no it's not
this is a chess
that's just what i would have done is it
is a chat and you're doing is it better
than me in the game
what are your goals i'm into them
in this round i wouldn't why would i
tell anyone that's true i don't know
it's good to say your goals would you
that way you can all be held against
what you're going to be
and then so then i can figure out let me
tell you tell me your goals
i'm just kind of hanging out i don't
really have a plan yeah me neither i'm
just kind of building roads where i see
fit
ruining other people's plans
i mean i'm just kind of trudging along
using a knife to
make sure that you can
just the laziest army
fiber
damn it come on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
riley
okay hey anyone got any um
um
that's good
brick
yeah yeah
you like sheep no
i don't
you like
rocks
please
oh i can do that
sick development card coming at me
yeah dvd nice dude thank you thank you
thank you
that's it that's it posted a roast of
dylan but he wasn't there so it just
looks like i was bullying him
i got i put it up on tick tock
he wasn't there
he said he got covered
i put it up on tick tock and i got like
a community
harassment for bullying oh nice
and harassment
like i'm harassing dylan
um are you are you going
i think that's all i can do
okay right
not until the next turn right right
me pass me the um yep there we go
do you dane to test me
some gas eight
eight
yes
it is all right they're just they're
just having a completely different
conversation in the chat
i know they're talking to each other
they're having their own podcast
well yeah i mean we don't ever tune in
that would be really
weird to be sitting there being like hey
guys
it's like hey guys uh in the chat can
you let us into your conversation
yeah i'd like to talk to us
okay what do you want to say
uh
ask them if they know any magic tricks
oh yeah dude
good question
ask them if they can uh
speak
another language
oh god this is taking forever
is there a brittle around oh yeah
sorry clothes already whoa
yeah don't look at my car i'm gonna be
right back
um
these guys are like so jokey
yeah
real real funny guys
real comedians look at you making fun of
me and making me feel bad so good you
are
do you have any snow
do you have any cocaine
this guy can hop on one leg that's
pretty good
all right prove it
oh you built the settlement there you
guys are really [ __ ] tight on one leg
oh my god i made the wrong choice i was
like i can go here he's gonna go this
head over there now that choice really
[ __ ] me
inception
what is your favorite are you hungry
okay
is it your turn i uh i'm done now
you were doing something this whole time
uh riley it's your
getting caught in the bed sheets we'll
get you all right can you roll the dice
yeah
their bodies turn brittle
uh
come on come on come on oh my god
hey
does anyone have any wood
or sheep
would you like uh rock or wheat
no i'll take both
clay for for both i'll give you one of
each for both
yeah
are you kidding
i can't give you any rock i can give you
a wii like i'd play monopoly with you
then
as long as we would be able to make any
deals monopoly is uh not playable
what do you mean
it's like better as an idea than it is
actual gameplay
how dare you make a mockery
pretty pretty city
six points riley joins the six point
crew are you done riley
yeah
hopefully i don't get lost like the
malaysian airlines why would you get
lost
what happens to some people six
finally
that is true
is that almond butter
imagine how we feel yeah
hey yeah why don't you [ __ ] uh say
something funny then
actually please entertain us i'm very
bored as well
we can read this later
like it'll save you
what oh yeah it'll be online unless you
want me to take it down
trippy
yeah
okay that'll be fun anyone have sheep
and wheat
or a wheat and
okay fine i just need some good dyes i
need some good dice throw
ten
that's good
that's a good strike
oh
i'm not gonna do a [ __ ] goddamn thing
though
it just sucks because the universe
doesn't
doesn't want me to win right now yeah
don't become a [ __ ] victim bro
no i'm not a victim
fall victim
to
victimhood
victim
i prayed
upon my victimhood
used it oh [ __ ] so i think we should get
alex
five six seven eight
and he has one card that is a
development card that isn't turned over
in a long time
so he probably has nine points
two three four five six seven
i have seven points
are you done or are you gonna uh i feel
like i'm
gonna win then
one two three
oh man this is the worst day of my life
yeah
this is the worst day of my life
like a little kid
as long as riley doesn't win yeah that's
a good point what is wrong with you guys
what's that development card right there
it's a victory point hans
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
man great work
that was this was really fun though
great job
way to go
i will say yeah that was fun wow i'm
really proud that my only limiting
factors were
rolling really shitty numbers
yeah
thank you pat for that you had one two
three four five six seven points
in the longest road
you had one two three points errol
oh so i did okay they had six points yep
you beat riley
high five in you he's beat
congratulations congratulations
congratulations everyone we're all
winners in line
it's just been the 67th annual
games
this is the most exciting moment from
district 9
what if this was like uh that was a lot
this was a squid game game you had to
play some good dan i would be like i'm
just i don't want to yeah what if this
was the first squid game patches won
yeah damn
but the winner means you died so
yeah actually like aztec soccer
captain the captain would die of the
winning team
when the aztecs played with a skull uh
well this is a riveting story when the
aztecs would play with this you get to
borrow us
you won oh yeah yeah the winner the
captain of the winning team was
sacrificed that's what you got for
winning so
wait you you die i try not to sacrifice
if you're the captain of the winning
team he's like the guy's going to get
like geez i open a window it almost
feels like at that point you guys i want
you to go out there and it's kind of
replaced on its own like maybe it's just
different words kind of thing
really not maybe that's
hard to describe him on the winning side
you know what i mean yeah
just with what we know at least how many
aztecs does it take to uh
kill yourself
anyway
yeah it's a blast
what a trip
that's weird you want to watch the back
again
just a homeless dude just staring off
into space 70
are they torturing that homeless man
there's like a russian behind me just
like making me dance or something
like you look like you're being
controlled on string exactly
hey look at that cgi dude
this guy is all over the world i'm
talking to myself you're at the last
supper
homeless white man spotted in
antarctica
he's just looking up in the desert
i wish someone cared about us enough to
photoshop us
yeah
maybe someday one day
maybe someday
i care i know i'll be photo shopping
we'd have to learn photoshop
you're going to be in tiananmen square
you're going to be in the on the moon
don't be a square in tiananmen square
be there be square
so uh what do you guys think about the
joe rogan's new club opening up
tell me about it
so how do you guys come
up right he's doing he's gonna is you're
gonna have katana is there gonna be
prizes
there's gonna be a little tan corner
that's gonna be where i i live are you
gonna serve pizza and
i bet it's gonna i bet it's gonna be uh
chicken it's gonna be buffalo chicken
dip i have abba at you oh my god it's
gonna be like spicy burgers
i know a fair bit but i don't know how
much i can say it was just raw elk
raw 45
it's the only food item
yeah you can uh work out there there's a
there's a dmt section
there's a float tank
do these go in here is that uh yeah
no
i don't know yet emp section
yeah
yeah that was the thing joe is like
section we're gonna have a lot of
policemen there and then tony was like
they're gonna turn a blind eye to weed
right
they better yeah i know it's gonna be
weird meetings of austin are
they're gonna have a lot coming
cops there
yeah it's like security
he's gonna have really good security
is he gonna have good insecurity
is he insecure
maybe if marc maron comes
yeah it's perfect for portland
yeah why do you say that because he's
sort of like grass roots
grumpy and yeah
grouchy
the classic grouch
well this was this has been um a really
fun time
um so thank you guys for bringing me
into this space
and allowing me to play settler's cup
tan
how fun
are you still high from thanksgiving
what does that mean
it's like very uh official hey everyone
we're gonna pray mode
is that like where you've got a lot of
your cultural
should we do a final prayer no it's um
like my dad's really
catholic
and uh like
like believed really heavily in god
kind of nice i think it's like one of
those really cool rituals that like
yeah meditative
introspective yeah we're also communal
right now so it's kind of nice to just
say some dumb [ __ ] or whatever
yeah i mean that's where i think i got a
lot of my public speaking uh
uh
reception
all right experience
from church yeah or school
which was a christian school for me oh i
didn't really speak and speak in school
i didn't speak at all
no i do
but i wasn't like
it was a school for the deaf
candice answer the question
candace
answer the question
one do you guys organize the tiles
i don't know
i use him in my bathroom
seventy nine dollars
awesome
no but what i was thinking earlier
a uh square foot say a square foot of a
house cost like 50 bucks
just what you can do is
a five dollar foot long cost five
dollars
just make your house out of subway
sandwiches save money
that could really work right i'm
surprised it has not been done yet it's
so much cheaper per square foot
yeah
once you have to do something to the
bread though
uh you can put it in gelatin that just
adds to the cost of labor and everything
so you're really just you know are you
really getting a good deal
gelatin's inexpensive that's a good
point but then they you're thinking
about labor
why would you put it in jealousy yeah
but your time is valuable
um
but i am in labor
the gelatin will not help
you
be laboring the point
yeah
their wives are in labor they're in
labor labor day
lights
labradoodle
labradoodle
that's true labradoodle yeah
yeah there's there's plenty there's
plenty of ways to live late
maybe they're penny labia
labinolabia
the last airbender
what are we doing now i forget
laboratory
laughing
lilted
wilted i love that word a little oozy
bird
a little techa
yeah
biblioteca
a little indian in the cupboard
read that book no very good just a funny
terrible name
yeah
it's about a little indian that lives in
the cupboard
comes
what isn't problematic you know what i
mean
um a good point
what is programmatic
um
uh when you're really into
grammar
online dating programs
i'm pro graham crackers i'm programmer
i love grammar
you love grammar grammar
who doesn't i like
i'm anti-grammar oh he's announcer
you look like an answer that makes sense
to me i'm bouncing right now oh boy i'm
bouncing off the walls yeah
he does this sometimes
outside of shelf yeah no ouncing in the
house
yeah well we got to do more denouncing
because that's key to keeping the
ouncing from bouncing
and that's uh
that is so dancing
i'm pouncing with delay
i'm getting ready to round
ronda round
ronda rousey
gary bucy
i have to do a little poopsie
i'll do the scoopsie
to catch it from the carpet i love lucy
no because it's not even your house
i love uh that i love that worked by wc
oh wow nice
the [ __ ]
the vagina
that could be the next dojo cat
dog
um
cruella with uh emma not emma watson um
i'm a stone
that was good i didn't see it it's like
a millennial she's been you guys see
louise special
yeah
did you yeah
how
bought it
what a chump
why i just got mine
you just gave money to a masturbator
well i give money to a masturbator every
time i
work
you shouldn't do that
you should stop masturbating and then
you can work
conscious that's what i say to my
grandma after she gave me a birthday
check you just gave money to a man
you just helped me masturbate 100
a federally known masturbator
i'm one of the best [ __ ]
i don't know if you know this but i've
been masturbating since
you guys ever catch your grandma
masturbating
so awkward
damn that's what i never even thought
about
my grandma's the worst thing is the
worst part is she doesn't even stop
riley can you get me a glass of water
she has her hands down her pants
would you take a look at this yeah keep
thinking it through riley
you're not supposed to think about your
grandma right here on out this is a good
idea going back broken yeah what
i wasn't really thinking about i was
just more just joking
just
it's called a fantasy
yeah they're all over town damn you're
you pretty high there hans green how are
you doing
what would you say like if you had
levels
1 to 13 or something and where would you
be that's a reasonable
little tiny
[ __ ]
i'm the boy
in
the army keep working with it
yes
i'm the white boy in the cupboard each
cupboard is a different race yeah
you're the indiana boy undercover hey
what
don't you open my damn cupboard
what you doing to open my cupboard
do we have any grits you got any grits
this is indiana in the cupboard yeah i
thought that was indiana no that's like
super southern uh
do y'all
do you all want to get a couple
uh tacos
getting closer
to indiana
do you all want to go to the milwaukee
bucks game probably eat like ketchup
spaghetti or something
you guys want to get some ketchup
spaghetti
beat my wife
do y'all want to go to ihop
yeah i could work
together
in one car we carpo one
it i think he's doing the character
during the indiana guy
thanks guys yeah and i'm not [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] guys will you let me play or not
jesus well you have to hop in it's like
double dutch yeah
i'm in man i'm good
i do want
how humans make decisions right there
that was it
that's everyone does this same thing
marijuana
well it's yeah it's like too fast like
if we catch anyone there's no until
they're okay
i'm uh i'm not picking up what you're
putting down but
what is an indiana accent
is it like it's like this it's like
oh look at them hamburgers they got
pickles on them now pickles i like on
hamburgers you put pickles on hamburgers
you got a nice burger i like that
what do you see
writing a thesis
uh
are pickles on a burger now i think it's
more like uh
no they're nothing's universal y'all
are we still it's level 0.2 it's like uh
well what i mean
hey i'm indiana i'm from indiana i feel
like this is getting problematic for you
hey i know
minnesota
i'm from minnesota
i live in indiana
that's like minnesota i'm from minnesota
i live in indiana yeah it's like that
kind of thing oh yeah it might be more
like that that's missing indiana would
you think that indiana would be like
something like that what do you think
a wise guy hey would you do would you do
a if i just hit you with an accent would
you do it let's do it everyone's trying
buckville
norman yet
i have no idea where that is just
[ __ ] do it dude
oh yeah oh we like a cookies in boopie
we have big houses
we dried reindeer
a driven reindeer there's nothing
nothing beats them oh
we
our poops are white
that's very unique to your region would
you what's that is that near this yeah
can you think of something else in your
off time
i'm from
jew
holy [ __ ]
it's pretty good but the thing is i've
definitely heard people who talk like
that
like in real life
people from denver
jubilee jubilee
denver you're a colorado kid
no i'm from seattle
oh yeah all right let's play a game
wherever where people do an accent you
have to guess what accent it is okay
i'll go first
oh my we going out for the ball
california oh mike hey mike there we go
german tourist
mate i'm telling you that's not mate
we're gonna go out to the beach have a
little barbie taxi cab confession or
that
but
uh australian yeah was it good nice
candice's turn
it just sounded too much like you
all right let me try it again let me try
again are you we're trying to what
action are you trying to do why you
sound different are you threatening us
with all you're gonna pull it out you're
like
what are you gonna try to try it out but
did you redo
it
yeah
we got a little bit of all right you go
i don't know i only have four now you're
feeling it man just flow it you keep
going dude just go full sentences now
though
i'll do it later all right maybe we
might we gonna go down with pope all
right i'm gonna tell him i'm gonna tell
him mate hey lily freaking
yeah you got it african that's africa as
a whole might almost that's not african
at all yeah yes ugly con is like this is
african yeah we've got dogs with all
rivers
i've been to africa yeah i don't know
it's icons i don't know about that south
africa
oh yeah
you're [ __ ] prawns mate
what are you gonna do about your prawns
we gotta kill these prawns i love that
it's such a difficult accent
it's so difficult in it
all right
you know like
something i find quite difficult is like
when you're trying to do an accent right
english
yeah
yeah right i don't speak like the queen
i speak like the queen
you're doing an upper class you're
[ __ ] i just also try to like work on
a really shitty one like
um
or what finn
it's like
all right
improvisational for once just do an
accent we all guess what it is
yeah it could be anything that's to be
real
oh a real one yeah like no
no yes yes
everything's real if you think about it
if it's not real we're never going to
get it
what was that one that was klingon
oh wow very very very impressive
i guess i always have to say that
because i'm like i guess did you try
hard at that like dude is there a school
i've heard people i've literally had
people say to me klingong's actually
very hard to learn honestly my the most
impressive thing about it is that it was
even created
all right i guess i think that's true
first
well no because like create a language
all right can i go all right feels true
to me no it's pat's turn
this you cannot do this not making sense
no no that's bad why are you gay
it was good at first they
have sex in their poopoos
why are you doing this why do you do
this
uh i don't want to do accents but i do
two movies i just quote two movies all
the time dumb and dumber
and big lebowski that checks out but
that's about it so that's pretty much
the whole package to me i feel like this
is
emoji you want to do a character you
were gonna pick like
like jeff bridges character from no yeah
and i'm into no i'm into jeff daniels
like his he's my spirit animal for sure
for sure for sure for sure yeah and jim
carrey is just like you know my home
like i wanted my turn all right hanza's
turn
yes when you go to the pub you go to
have a little uh how you say a little
dance and a little in the [ __ ] uh yes i
like up
turning the ball up
yes i like it when you do that hey
something or look don't try
france are you i'm from france
we
i have like ten dollars in my pocket
i do not like these snails
would you like to sniff my armpit
that sounds uh would you like to come
over that sounds like a tape you're
learning like a language and it's like
someone who's a spanish speaker speaking
english
specifically
it's like you buy like one of those
tapes the guy just like obviously does
not know the language he's just like
making sure he's like you know for
french you just kind of have to talk
like this
you do you know francois soto
yeah break it down
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's come
bring it in bring it ring it
like hater but i can't think of it
i love you i love it i think yeah push
harder
not too hard i love them and i love you
know oh you know what i love you know
how like that thing where like people uh
open your eyes you're trying to like
keep your lights like keeping uh keeping
stuff like at a temperature like if you
want to keep it cold so then
you it's got like a there's a little
house where it's like a box
and then there's people will uh actually
it's like you know some it's a kind of
og stuff they'll go to your house and
they take these things right and
it's giant the inside the truck is a
giant thing of uh ice
oh dry ice people just pick it up and
then they put it in the box ice bath oh
you're making fun of me that's what
that's what that is that accent yeah no
that's what it is actually yeah wow what
an ice picker yeah it's the ice paper
all i do is
ice
i don't know what you're trying to do
i'm not tracking it
you seem to be like brother and sister
on this you're like dude yeah
no i was just trying to be like
someone would cut me off how long i
would just go for the dumbest place
wait what was the first you're breaking
it all down he's over solving all the
riddles over here [ __ ] pat's like
putting it all together pat's like oh
you try it you try to come the whole
thing huh on the day of my daughter's
wedding must be greek
greek
oh great knows what greek says it's like
a greek word
homeless like
i feel like greek would be
it's like a smoker
a greek a tough greek like father
i think you're not you don't go there
you don't go to the school
you can speak like fake greek in that
voice like
uh
extra crispy
chicken in the basement you know i like
my calamari oh that's a different thing
[ __ ] oh
bro
i find it
all right candace's turn
just do it flow into a dog just feel it
flow she's five
oh i can't i'm not gonna do it i'm not
gonna i can do like four accents and i i
don't want to do it it's two different
countries indian russian chinese okay
uh scottish scottish irish asian
general asian asian
everyone with small eyes talks the same
yeah i know that it just comes out their
faces
for their eyes
yeah unless this means more no i don't
have i'm going to skip errol
well
whoa
sesame street
who knows language has stuttering built
into it oh yeah well
yes dude
anyways
i
oh i do i just like when people have it
that's fine
bros
we lost seven one to germany
it was like our 911 russian
uh
netherlands
portuguese i was doing roger and del
santos
oh so
oh my friend you must you do
i be [ __ ] my wife
cause he doesn't say that
okay i think he says that he has a joke
a coconut as helmet
we did not
i am the top head present
tonight
is that brazilian accent or deceased
like have his own accent he has his own
accent
probably it's not even a brazilian
accent i guess you're doing it brazil we
very much like brazil
yeah
mentally yeah
yeah
yes japanese and san paulo dr peterson
we will help you with this problem you
know how to help you with your
weird mental diagnosis
yes you it's a viability
uh
i can't do anything whatever
hey
jamaica you're making me crazy man
hey good time good time here
you're staying strong you want to
bobsled man
boxer time
i don't even remember what it sounds
like anymore
i just like anything like that
it's like a vibe
i am japanese
and i have tiny penises
oh did you watch a squid game
that's why you go to china to find that
out
why you do that here is this getting
problematic or is it not i can't tell i
feel like it might be yo man why don't
you just shut the [ __ ] up
i feel like this is uh
is that one sweeter
i feel like i just do like 400
variations of like a white guy but
that's really what i got but lucky for
us there's like 400 variations
white accents yeah let's do white
accents
japanese
love japanese yeah
oh my god this one
i'm not saying that what is it hair
hitter
hitler i love hitler he is so funny
yeah
i love her
this is me in the 1940s
not me but someone else
hitler is like
i can't even do it
that's good
and we love the guns in this country wow
very big guns
oh god that's pretty good
ah
i love it hitler is such a good guy
we still going with this one i don't i
feel like what do you think about the uh
well how do you write a joke how do i
write a joke yeah
it's like you haven't been listening to
me at all hans
[ __ ] time i've been here or have you
been riffing and
drifting this whole time
riffing and drifting and grifting and
dropping it that's how you
conversational for like a year
what is your favorite
open mic that you've done
the first time i did the holy [ __ ] show
it was [ __ ] dope that was crazy oh is
that the one that has uh like the god
and stuff
jesus
you're dressed up as jesus in the poster
yeah the poster came out great the whole
thing came together really quick it was
like it was just like random yeah and
like you got to cut off someone if you
felt like they weren't riffing enough
well because i didn't know what i was
doing i knew it was a time limit
yeah i never went
because i've been thinking about oh it
was just like
people were like what do i do and it'll
be like just be you man
like what it's like
i'm really trying to work on something
the third dude just stood up he was up
there and he just stood and he goes i
want to [ __ ] punch this dude
right in the eyes he's like 6'3 and i'm
sitting back there and i'm looking like
this but i got a big old beer and i just
kick i'm kicking back here's the mic
isn't it just like oh yeah i'm just like
kicking back and i'm just like
oh [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] am i getting
into you know because i'm just in this
like we're all goofing around i've never
been part of comedy or whatever i'm not
coming in
so i just knew what i wanted it's easy
to be funny wild
well it's like a lot of people do stand
up comedy as a career and they kind of
uh approach it from like a myth like you
know they're trying to express
themselves like an art all the time
instead of like actually just being
there and doing comedy and being like
funny
um
yeah if you're just like oh this is just
a game that we're playing let me just
play along
but if you're like this is my voice
and i need to practice on how i'm going
to tell the government that they're
wrong yeah it's definitely like a it's a
fine balance so sometimes it's like good
to have
both styles but like you don't want to
be too young to rock it no just kidding
i'm saying that because it's obviously
he's doing great it's just like
we can't be in
yeah he's i mean he's working on stuff
too like you can see him work out stuff
and do stuff so it's like if you go to
mics and stuff you see them work it out
and like yeah whatever so it's it's
still it's just like a different method
it has amazing jokes yeah and they're
just they're so unique
yeah and it's like everyone thinks it's
just so like whatever but it's so well
done like it's not just like a [ __ ]
he's like uh you know he's actually
working on it his jokes are so like he
would kill still if he didn't if he
wasn't so high energy but he just like
like he would already kill because his
jokes are good yeah i said graham i
don't think he's worried about killing
him
i just don't even cares about it at all
are you a tiss guy or are you a dirty
dirty ass guy i don't ruin the punch
line but i thought he says like he had
to go bit one time i was just like kill
her like he just says it what did he say
oh yeah there's like one where he's like
uh
i don't want to like use it like i want
to ruin his jokes like those are his but
like he like whenever he's not doing
well it's whole or he think he proceeds
he doesn't say something it's just like
so [ __ ] funny and there's like this
one it's a timing thing yeah i've seen
them do it do this one
before and i've heard about it and then
i finally saw it and it's so funny it's
like
he knows where the laugh should go and
if they don't come then he has something
to say like hell yeah brother yeah but
it's also yeah i'm gonna blair witch the
rest of the set
it's funny yeah it's hard to talk about
without ruining his bits yeah
absolutely but it's just it's one of
those things where it's like uh it is
like what he's doing isn't just like
haphazard like it's it's methodical and
i think people don't realize that yeah
like we know because we do comedy yeah
but then people should realize i'm not
claiming that oh [ __ ] about it he's like
[ __ ] with them well yeah but it's
also like you know you can see him like
work out stuff and it's really cool to
like yeah yeah it's great it's good it's
so pretty it's like such a unique and
special skill but like also
very unique like style yeah that's what
he's he's pure of heart he doesn't have
like a malicious bone in his body he's
yeah
there's an evil one of him running
around
yeah dude who's your who's the good
version of riley
what
your ego's out of control yeah
you need to bring the other oh my god my
ego is like
at a very sensible speed well just sit
down and just have a good talk that
sounds like ego talking my ego is on
cruise control my ego is doing so good
right now
yeah no no but this is the worst that's
the worst version of ourselves my eyes
light up in the dark
riley is like he's more dangerous
i can see it i can see you being way
weird
honestly
evil riley is like dean stanfield
whoa i hang from the ceiling so kind
upside down yeah like jonah hill it's
just two different these are all just
different things candace
thank you riley appreciate that
slytherin yeah like hey man you've
changed
you doing all right
i haven't said in a while
okay bro all right man thank you like
we got so we got all sorts of [ __ ] girls
got peanut butter that's [ __ ] he
wants him he wants some brittle you want
some brownie
you want some brownie brittle brown
hey ariel's got this tiny ass doggie
the [ __ ] is that you know what i mean
total bystander kind of deal there this
was a nice appetizer
but i'm a little peckish
all right
it's a living room there's three pieces
of furniture okay
i think it's tough for you as a snake
i'm going to turn off the lights
well i will guess kind of see it when it
happens won't we
one
two
three all right now you can't see
anything
oh wow oh oh
you know what i'm gonna keep distracting
you until my eyes adjust
okay
this is really weird um the ego is
strong with this one
yeah i mean uh
that's my word
i'm done my tongue once riley starts
doing voices
it's nice
who's smoking who yeah
okay hey how much do you pay for that it
was that like medical pursuit he's even
in there anymore you know riley
who is the real
real sad self for the first time this is
such a distraction my tongue is cut into
a triangle
focus on the tongue and go inward
you're like a met kind of meditation
just meet him where they are
just riley doing this [ __ ]
it's like your cool support most
autistic asmr ever
where are you going you can't sleep now
i am everywhere
who are you i am in your dreams your
dreams
good night sweet prince
have you ever read the little prince
have you ever read that book yeah you
like it yeah
what do you like about it
i like that he goes uh he has his own
spaceship and he can like kind of go
around in his own spaceship
it's a nice part uh i like the part
about the drawings yeah yeah i like the
part that he ends up in the
like it's like this
like tropicana type place and he's able
to harvest the banana leaves
to make a cool hat yeah so that he can
afford his family's medical bills
that's what's up you know
that's like some bringing that oh [ __ ]
that's
you know that book
little prince little prince
it's probably one of my favorite plot
lines
it's like 50 pages or something it's
like a little kid it's it's crazy how
much emotion they're able to evoke about
the medical bills thing which is such a
fun
short block right in the beginning
you're drawing the snake have you have
you read it hans no oh well yeah
check her out should we do a live
reading on the podcast oh i'd read it
out loud dude
i think it's showed up as a pdf yeah
we're
what are you talking about snake humor
doesn't translate
through these humans
i'm having a great time
my smile honestly i don't think this is
a bomb this is not a true bomb this is
good this is gold yeah you i think this
is money audience yeah you guys are bomb
you don't get our high concept art i'm
sorry sorry
it's too high we're losing you i mean
it's just
what is
what is good
love twizzlers but not the regular ones
i love the nibs
you nibber
um you ever [ __ ] with that i can't say i
have done it i mean we could do another
accent
circle again
nothing zoom oh we should read it
was that
i don't know
like a valley girl yeah oh i can do that
yeah like oh my god no that's the wrong
one oh every girl has the valley girl
deep inside them yeah yeah let's get
into white women voices that's a fun one
yeah
oh my god
that is like so crazy
and also so random
how could it be so random oh my god
that you have to go blog about this now
literally it's just like not even but
it's never random
and it's not surprising it's literally
like not even and they say literally a
lot
literally
like oh my god you'll not believe it
like literally
i literally can't big as a house
last night at the this i went to ty's
house show
and he's like the spot you know yeah
for thai food
wild it's the same thing
yeah this is thai food
i love
thai food you do too it's like who said
that
uh everyone in portland from i don't
know 2006 to 2000 yeah that checks out
yeah why people love anything they
perceive to be um ethnic
and they kind of love they claim to love
it the most and then they and it's sauce
[ __ ] well it's like they like they like
soy sauce and noodles they like food and
like foreign food is made by white
people
well it's like if it's like a fun
atmosphere to go to it's like let's eat
tacos
i think it's more basic now i think oh
that's me i want i ruin that i run the
round sorry guys mustard hairs mustard
hat that's me oh
you called you a dude too that's fine
that checks out
and it's uh really starting to stress me
out
yeah i mean we weren't even doing
the internet is a cold cold place
you were doing an accident you actually
participated in the round i think you're
doing great i think everyone's doing
fine
i think you're fine i think you're fine
hell yeah
god bless it god bless you dude so
what if there was just like
uh
never mind i wanna do this on the
podcast
who do you hate the most in the austin
comedy scene and booker's
your top five
i would say my least favorite right on
pat hates himself my favorite booker is
santa
booker t
should we get booked at the library oh
we should do that we should see them
like if they want to you can read them
remember we're going to read the little
prince
we should do a gorilla comedy show in a
library like it's like what if it was
like a 30 second comedy show and it's
like comics just go good and then before
everyone gets kicked out
yeah oh it's just like be really loud
how about we just like really well you
just come through with the microphone
and [ __ ] and then you just do like a
quick little like one little bit and
then you just like move on to the like
you know what i mean yeah that'd be a
good idea where like we have an audience
but we just go whisper our jokes into
their ears yeah love it love that oh my
god let's see who can get most laughters
from it's like out in the thing
okay comedy show where everyone has
those headphones where everyone's going
channel you are already waiting there's
just different all different comics
doing their jokes so everyone's laughing
at different times oh and then because
it's like in the djs they do that where
you kind of there's like three djs
playing jams yeah you choose a channel
channel yeah so that would be kind of
cool and everyone's just like just like
three canadians and then people are
choosing channels their lights are
different right yeah and then people
think you're laughing at a holocaust
joke but you're actually laughing at us
and you just choose like the crate like
the craziest mix of three comics and so
you're just like it's kind of like this
would be really fun yeah it's like
telephone
no
[ __ ] up bro can you do that in a voice
that's what i was thinking of yeah you
can only talk in voices now really evil
riley you can only
yeah did you get the telly we should do
telephone right now oh little gamer
telly yeah
i'll do it no it's gonna be so easy we
did this last time it was so easy
yeah it's so fun when you get it
accurate
it's just people whispering to each
other it's just a really slow way to
communicate
it's way more funny
they have that they already have like a
like my open mic or something like that
no but that's the whole set right you
should just be joked by joking actually
in a line of people so like maybe by the
end oh that'd be kind of funny so it's
like it's yeah
what if like the first so what it would
be is like a line of comics one the
first comment goes telephone's a joke to
the end comic and then moves to the back
of the line
yeah
are kind of fun
uh telephone is hard to
watch though because you can't hear them
yeah well you can
what's going on
you can like get in on the suspense yeah
i think it'd be fun like you have like
it wouldn't even take that long you know
what about like picture where you draw a
picture on someone i love that oh i like
i like to play that game where you so
like everyone has a piece of paper you
draw a picture and then you fold it and
so you pass it and the person looks at
the picture writes a sentence and the
next person only sees the sentence and
has to draw a picture the next person
like alternates to the internet
that's how the bible was written yeah
fun fact fun fact
actually another fun fact i just met
this guy who's apparently a scholar on
the bible and he's coming out with a new
book
that is no no
no no no no review but he's just gonna
he knows who wrote the bible
so he figured out who wrote the book i
wrote the bible well i know but you know
he's taking his guess at it yeah
god wrote it
they're calling the book
this'll get us killed
or something like i think it's like that
it's like this might get a shot whoa
yeah who is it i think this might give
us kills way better with title yeah but
i mean i'll let him know that we
workshopped it well you know sometimes
it's important to have those
conversations
wait so who who wrote the bible well i
don't know god i know the guy who thinks
he knows well it's
god you think i'm a guy trying to call
that kind of card dude i can't call like
what i'm going to eat for you know and
you know
what
because why
what uh
well
we should what's your religion jews my
religion yeah yeah i don't have one of
those
or would you describe it as
on a census
some pretty mormon chill-ass [ __ ] some
some uh
thinking things through some uh calm
logicianry
so
you need to improve your elevator pitch
if you're going to start a cult
yeah i don't want to start basically
just like kind of whatever i would say
yeah that'd be pretty basic [ __ ] i mean
that's like they don't believe in god
well everything's pretty rep your set
what rubber said
what do you think represent
i'd probably say
agnostic which is atheists but i just i
knew it i hope that agnostic is a little
different it's different you're still
holding a hope yeah what are you candice
blind um this isn't quite how it is i
don't know how to explain it it's like i
don't really necessarily believe there
is like a god like i don't believe it in
any of the traditional senses but that
like uh there is like some kind of like
energy within the universe that is god
that's god
is that god i mean yeah that's kind of
the best that's the worst thing that's
been happening but with religious
christians
it's what it means to me and it's just
like it's like i don't i don't answer to
it i don't do anything like that it's
just like it's an energy that like i
feel like you can yeah tap into it
your own you're your own god energy
equals mass times velocity of light
squared so wow
that's a good point photons and carbon
and
a little energy you don't have to
believe in god it's like this literally
is god like we're in god right now
that's this is everything
god is right
then here's my question is there a
direction to
this god thing you're describing that is
the right direction is there a direction
to me
or is it or the whole thing like are we
moving somewhere are we staying still
i don't think
it just is
yeah it just is
there's an energy that we can tap into
or be aware of yeah okay that's what i
feel like that's kind of how i vibe with
things and i feel like
i don't know it's definitely like very
individualistic i don't believe in like
a collective maybe unit for like
organized religion i think everyone
experiences whatever i've experienced
differently and that's their version
right the same organized religion really
[ __ ] it up yeah they really [ __ ] it
up they really made some mistakes i
think the boy [ __ ] thing was really
bad but
i think everything else was pretty not
chill too for sure actually yeah you're
right
that's what they're known for if they're
right
any publicity is good publicity
they're like we gotta get in the
newspapers
they're like we're just
they're like
let's
call one man and one woman
nice
that's like first bifurcation or not
first but one early one
you know taking a simple kind of whole
concept human and then go male but one
of you
is actually wears dresses whatever you
know we just put some reflection on it
like better at that da da da yeah it
could be true or not it really is
pointless something like sex is like so
obvious it's like you have a dingus and
you have holes to put it in it's not
hard to figure it out you know no one's
like yeah i don't know what to do
anymore what does this have to do with
religion though because religion started
the whole thing they go and then what
happened was adam and eve dude it's the
that's the first thing like then there
were two yeah and so that's a
bifurcation that's a relative vision
religion creates
division
i mean i think uh religion is a great
way to enforce your will upon the
populace that might not be for their
best interest yeah obviously but that's
like level one thinking
there's like three more levels on top of
that you know one of them is like
gender is
dividing us or something absolutely yeah
i think
i don't know
sure
um
i mean there's no i mean you guys are
listening to me like i'm telling you
like it's working god i'm just no we're
just all we're all discussing i mean
none of us are gonna have the exact same
belief like it just doesn't exist
because even if like the same like
organized whatever people are still
going to their interpretation because
it's pretty challenging
we're like monkeys and we're trying to
perceive reality through a mechanism
that was used to run away from leopards
so we're not going to have like a very
good understanding of the universe yeah
you call a monkey what we think is
reality is probably like we need to
believe in some spiritual [ __ ] because
we don't have the mechanism to conceive
of that
so is you just have to take a leap
with your monkey soft fleshy brain some
may call that faith
it sounds a lot like it
what do you think about the idea that
language is a prison that when you like
mention monkeys it's like if we didn't
like have language we would just be like
living
true
all these other things creating a
reality yeah i don't think
i i i like that yeah i think i don't
know if it's like languages
no i believe in it i think you're dead
on i think i thought it would be a lot
easier to communicate without language i
think language like kind of uh
like
verbally
i think i think the nuance to language
is what gives it if language in itself
was like inherently not something that
would have like subtext and stuff like
that and like what was said what was
said with like no sarcasm like or
inflection or exception with built in
within the phrase like open
interpretation it would be more that way
but because it's it's almost limiting
because you can never really take
something at face value all the time
because language is so nuanced
once one person starts lying
or even word choices maybe it's the
other person's perception based on
inflection or what their word choice was
so that was interesting let me just do a
little bit more of that to get the
result that i intended yeah so it could
be all sorts of different things so yeah
i mean i don't know it's limiting in
that way it'd be i think if it was more
precise it would be awesome but i think
like we're coming from a traumatized
time in like the 1900s
and our language and communication is a
product of that and if we have like a
healthy time then maybe we could be more
honest where we don't have to lie to
make sure that we're going to survive
because like right now we change our
language to appease our bosses that
introduces inauthenticity into our
social
uh construct of language well it's like
code switching
yeah
and there's always going to be some
degree of that but i think like if it's
coerced yeah and it's four years
survival well there's just no way that
you can live
i think like just all the limitations
that i've put on society i like religion
is great in a lot of ways but it's a
limitation the way like governance like
power like all these things are really
detrimental to the human experience
yeah
or can be
i think that's the thing is like all
these things are there's nothing that's
absolute is about any of this of course
but then everything does
have this kind of
feeling where it's kind of like trying
to decide how to like go hard at life
but also be chill at life i mean how do
we you know it's like make something of
it and create this meaning but at the
same time it's like but that meeting is
different per person
i don't want to do a vacuum i don't want
to be a vacuum salesman my whole life
you know i mean i just that's
yeah and that's i don't want to but some
people do and so no no i'm not against
it yeah i'm just saying everyone's
attack at life is different and like
what what what how they're going to
balance like what is like what they want
to do versus like like how that what
they want to make of this life it's like
that's the coolest thing about human
experience i think is just but i wish
people were more relinquished from that
mental prison and like the work going to
work and thinking that's like the best
way
to live your life like that sucks dude
[ __ ] that yeah i mean the first thing to
go is authenticity if you have to
survive if you have to struggle to for
food or
nazi germany or war so it's the other
way i'd say that authenticity goes away
when you don't after i think
authenticity is introduced by
essentially like the higher class
creating having to create drama when
you're bored you create drama when
you're not and you're like surviving you
don't you have literal language yeah you
can get [ __ ] done
but if you have to like think a certain
way to survive taylor created a lot of
drama that's a good point there's like
you got to be nice to me well for sure
and also something to consider
yeah
that's good a lot of what
drama yeah
oh my gosh what do you mean to get rid
of that because jews are dramatic
that's cool dude that's just a little
bit um
problematic
do you really think that relaxing and
having a good time creates
inauthenticity like if you're having too
much leisure time then that close to
that idle time idle i mean if it's too
comfortability essentially i think like
too much comfortability leads to
essentially i do believe that it's kind
of idle hands you know written right i
mean i think that's like what they tell
us but i don't think that's true i think
that like if you're inauthentic like
i mean if you have everything met for
you like uh
there's no reason to be inauthentic the
only reason for inauthenticity is if uh
you have to for some reason but i think
we're talking about two different things
you're talking about like base needs met
i'm saying yeah if your base needs are
met i think you can be very authentic
that's probably your primo authenticity
is right at base means net and then not
a whole lot more but i'm saying that
it's when you get a whole lot more than
base needs met that you then now are
just kind of living in the sea of
abundance
and it's essentially impossible not to
be constantly taking advantage of other
people just by doing your deal if you
invest at all it's like you've got to
have people think so why are you taking
advantage of people just because you
have a lot of comfort well i think it's
also like to your point where you're
talking about if you live in a world
where you have to be uninauthentic now
you're literally um
hiring these people in your world to be
inauthentic to you because you have the
means to do so you're creating you're
creating your own lessons and everyone
else's has to be authentic too yeah you
can't just be authentic by yourself and
also if you have every need met why
would you need to hire people to be
inauthentic to you
yeah yeah but then you also have to
restate the with the definition of needs
like right like in like what like if you
have emotional needs
or if you're like you have all this
survival instinct and you have nowhere
else to put it so you put it towards
[ __ ] over people or
something like that but i think like if
everyone is healthy like it doesn't like
we're just used to a system where that's
not the case so we just think that this
is always going to be the case we're
going to do that but i don't know
i don't think that we're going to do
that necessarily do you think you need
to toil every day
no
no i've
toil i don't have to do something that
kind of sucks but benefits you like i
think farming not that extreme but yeah
you do i think there's a little bit of
me that definitely and i don't think
it's the ultimate like system i think
that's just like something that's hard
no i know yeah i think you have to work
to live i think you can change how you
feel about work and make it a positive
thing i don't think work has to be
negative
and you have to work to live and you can
also have to change what your needs are
to be able to be sustained by that you
know what i mean yeah
but i think
but i mean why are we just so content
with just like oh it's life sucks like i
think that
i don't believe that like uh it's going
to be miserable what if it's going to be
a lot of toil and work i think that uh
there's too much of that it's a puritan
mentality yeah yeah but i just think
those [ __ ] puritans [ __ ] puritans
have never nothing's ever been the same
so they came to this [ __ ] country uh
i think yeah i hope people don't like do
it too much but it's like the same thing
as like running i wouldn't suggest
running all the time right
but after running you get that good
feeling yeah so i focus on the five
minutes of misery yeah the positive well
it's also like it's just like little
things throughout the day where like i
i've had there's like points in time
when i've had too much time on my hands
and it's i don't think it's a social i
don't think it's like a social thing
that makes me feel that way it's just
like i truly have to have like a little
bit of like
struggle whether it be mental or
something going on
i need to like
we need a little bit of it but i think
right now it's like we have too much of
it in general and i feel like i got a
good i got a decent amount sometimes it
is too much but i feel like my misery
level is pretty good it's a misery well
in terms of like other countries oh yeah
this is getting me bigger than
i mean yeah but i mean you can't just
bring it up
yeah that's a good point riley always
has the best one like that's a good
point they're not americans so who cares
yeah
they don't vote here they can't vote i
vote not like anyone does
i mean i would like to try to do my best
here or try not to be miserable or
something
yeah well i mean you don't really have
to try it i think the whole thing's
skewed again from this as i was saying
before i'm not miserable you call this
like gender dilemma
there is no
misery and not misery it's just this
idea i mean so there isn't like slogging
through stuff but obviously if the story
that you that one decides to paint is
that when i'm in these like
modes of whatever it is where i feel
like i'm grinding or hard or it's
difficult or i have to push through then
it feels better on the other side when
i'm taking a bath or chilling out or
whatever i think that's super fair and i
think it's a good way to just kind of
get out productivity and honestly i
think it's more just like where you are
in life like when i was 20
you have energy to do crazy [ __ ] you
know you're just like 20 to 30. i mean
you just do whatever the [ __ ] you want
you just feel good um and then it's not
like i feel bad now but i know
instinctively i just have no interest in
some of the [ __ ] that i just dumped tons
of energy into
you know just to do it
with no thought
yeah and you know this just may happen
so i think there's just kind of the
short term it's miserable but if you
look long term then it's not so it's
just what scope that you decide to look
at it through
yeah for sure and what you decide your
misery to be yeah
yeah i mean i'm a guy who's super not
miserable at all i'm a guy who's saying
i don't think you need misery in the
game i don't prescribe to the idea that
there has to be again to the yang and
the good bad oh yeah but sometimes like
i'm just insane sometimes yeah like
they're all the time
i think so that's to be motivated by a
boss or like someone telling you what to
do or like i'm not discriminating i
don't know i i think for it's just like
i have like an internal like
push to do things that i want to do in
life and whatever but i think
i i go through these phases of like
really intense like high levels of work
and then really low levels sometimes
where i'm just like going crazy like
people don't i don't know people never
see that side of me where i'm just like
[ __ ] insane um and it's pretty cool
um but it does like i feel like i
couldn't live without that side of
myself
i just like lose my mind it's like hard
to explain um it's not that bad do you
go on a rampage no
i feel like you would you it's evil
riley speaking what
i was out with riley once on sixth
street
and some girl was really mean to him she
was like bye bye we are done with you
bye bye bye
and then she was like get your friend
out of here and i was like what
i was just trying to talk to you why do
you like that and then we were walking
down 6th street back to our car and it
was like why is this
why do they have to do this like that
i was really mad at them yeah
i was mad at them because uh i didn't
like that they uh
like didn't understand me
i was like you don't understand me you
don't you don't get me well don't try to
be understood on sixth street you don't
you discredit me
i just felt discredited
it's not the place for understanding
i know yeah i was just hammered
misunderstandings
that's the one that gets me i mean
that's still like my trigger point i
figured that out just being
misunderstood nothing else can get to me
just being misunderstood you got
misunderstood on the stairs leading down
to kiko's dock that one time that was a
pretty big misunderstanding
yeah wait what tall well
uh something happened and then arrow was
walking down and uh this other comic was
walking up and then arrow was like hey
man sorry about whatever and it's like
don't touch me i was a derrick
out of his way to kind of leave that
name out of it
just don't say his last name oh yeah
that it could be anyone
i told you that i don't like to be
touched yeah so he says that but then
like uh like he it's not like i care
because it wasn't like in
a malice or like ill-willed way but he
like put his hand on my back like
patting me on the back or whatever and i
was just like you literally have a rule
about not [ __ ] people touching you
and then you're gonna talk like don't
[ __ ] touch me like he's a toucher but
he can dish it but he can't take it he
can touch
but he can't feel
he's autistic okay
this is three hours and 39 minutes into
it so hopefully it won't i just want to
say since it just got brought up i still
might i still don't
like to me it's just
i don't know what i [ __ ] did it did
no i didn't touch him i know it's just
he has a problem with that
i can only name three people that he has
had this issue with but i don't know i
mean literally it was because he didn't
get up on the show
but then he did get up on the show like
he was up you know what i think it is is
because your mic and his energy level is
very similar like you're sort of the
wacky guy and he wants to be he finds
you like a threat like a blonde that's
yeah i know i know he does that but
that's why i was trying to hit him
straight on and he just hasn't budged
every time i see him i go are we cool
and he goes no and i go cool all right
he's yeah he's got like i mean what i
don't know what he wants what do you
think is going to happen you know it's
like a guy keeps being like bro
be cool it's okay no one's coming to the
right coming for your phone there's also
one that way too
yeah i mean
it's i wanted well i liked him i met him
we were in the same hostel he's very
smart he's smart he's got interesting
jokes i mean he's just like a [ __ ]
you know he's a dude he's a very focused
on this stuff divisive character and uh
very interesting topic of discussion he
said the n word a couple times what
maybe we should just feeling it
yeah air we're gonna talk about it some
other time yeah okay i'm just saying i
know i have no issue with them i mean
that's the part where it's weird for me
it's like literally the guys yelled in
my face three times and i'm like i still
have no issue
we have the people's court i have to
strike all of this for the record uh
errol uh we you can approach the bench
and we'll discuss the structure we'll
discover we'll discuss this further in
chambers
i ain't seen nothing
i don't think it's a big deal let's get
some questions in the chat
let's uh let's uh get some question uh
from hey if you love texas donate a
dollar
oh [ __ ] that dog's been there the whole
time yeah if you guys love riley and
want to support his uh dedication to
evil
please donate five dollars dedicating
myself to charities around the world
which ones are you gonna send yourself
to there's no questions uh we got no
questions in the chat um
toys for tots and talking with
themselves i think why do they hate us i
don't think it's like that i'm just
kidding i like to say i wasn't jumping
with the charity toys for thoughts
we give uh little
race cars to
[ __ ]
goddammit
y'all know of any uk comedians yomi
what's an uk
united kingdom
do you remember doing that little uh
actually
uh jg wentworth
i don't know
jg wentworth
all right seven seven cash no no y'all
know what oh
you don't know any of them
you carry comedians i can't do that oh
my god you're like rebel wilson can we
get any business that's annoying
oh did you hear it
uk
what
derek definitely has a fat [ __ ] oh my
god dude how's it what
what has a fat show
yeah i heard that from multiple people
it's so [ __ ]
hey he's got a fame
dude well the pro the worst part is he
he didn't ask he he just asked people to
get booked and then tell them what the
theme was
and then afterwards told them
after the show was booked and so they
were just like really offensive to
people like that's just not like you
can't do that like are you
yeah i do i'm so lucky
i would have been like i would have been
like i would have popped the [ __ ] off i
would have like been like
you are cordially invited
they're gonna love this i got an idea
this is gonna be so good
it's like being a cat and a cat don't
worry there'll be food in the green room
we spend most of our budget on
your food your sloppy
i am your god
way to go hard man you stuck that one
out
you you had so much resistance in your
face and you pushed through it's
beautiful
this is her this is my this is me doing
you finally here's my this is
hungary
the hunger is strong with this one
hey we actually had to rent
uh graded chairs
do you think so conversely do you think
he'd be pissed if uh people booked like
just autistic comics
i would go though i mean himself as
autistic
well i wanna wait what he thinks he
looks like i want him to draw himself
oh that's a good idea
dude that's a good idea for a show to
draw your thoughts
my main issue is still like i'm pro
autism i'm pro all the stuff
you're like not anti-autism like what a
strong stance like i'm pro-autism
know i'm like separating myself from you
guys i'm literally
no you're just like i'm trying to
impregnate women
45 years and older dude i'm ready
[ __ ] i am so pro-autism
i'm actually i'm actually so pro-autism
that i am a pro-choice but i want to
push the baby back in just to give it
more okay
what's your stance on tiny trains ooh
me yeah tiny trains yeah i am i'm into
them i think they're cool i don't have
any myself i don't know if i'd be much
of a collector but i love that people
have tiny anythings miniature anything
it's cute don't troll them completely
yeah you do the whole thing it's like
silent no one's i mean trains are one of
the more annoying features of our world
that and i love training [ __ ]
helicopters no trains are cool that's
always true transitions last forever
sometimes you know how many uh
immigrants lose limbs and die on trains
every year how many
immigrants i was asking if you knew
i don't know or people who are traveling
to get out of like whatever they're kind
of like you don't mean traveling
countries train hoppers
train hoppers but there's like
specifically people coming uh maybe this
is just the narrative that has been said
yeah the question is do you know how
many south america yeah south america up
through uh
to new mexico to mexico new mexico to
mexico
where's the small though are they going
out together dude what if it's small
small dog's just frozen in an ice block
outside oh my god he's trying to open
the door
they're doing the circle the dog the
human centipede the dog
there's someone in their king
i went out that's so adorable and the
dog went out with him the tiny dog's
like this is a big door
yeah i mean that's it and you have to go
from the bottom flap it's like can you
imagine if you're like it hit a garage
door that was just a big rubber flap and
you had to get through it
just like yeah i don't really know yet
suck but dogs do everything with their
face they kill animals with their face
yeah they like that like they're
yeah
yep
i think it's trying to get in it's like
no you made this decision i'm sorry bud
yeah
stern faraday that's great
sure it's okay
what do you think she's gonna die
instantly
what if they start playing and then he's
like you're the one who said she has
like seizures randomly and you're like
ah [ __ ]
she's fine let's take her out of sight
for a while no you guys are right do you
guys want to team up and raise her
together as a try i already have my own
dog so i'm good
we could just we can just
you're right you know how how am i
supposed to comment on your parenting
style when yeah i'm not you're right
okay at least we first wanted to come
full circle i'm feeling better hans yeah
how do you feel shameful good i feel
fantastic
what were you talking about i think we
had a good rift going and then i got
this we're talking about the fat fox
thing and then the autism show oh the
autism spectrum
yeah i wouldn't say it's too far i'm
just i'm drawing a connection being like
how how [ __ ] it would be to be like
hey i'm gonna book you for the show and
then you get person gets really excited
and then it's like hey it's because
you're
a fat
it's like the weirdest thing too because
it's like it's like a it's like a
santa's workshop theme it's like that's
the worst why would you want a fat elf
they're like the most inefficient
[ __ ] workers like that's the worst
why wouldn't he just make it like some
kind of other fat theme like uh
i had it my brothers that was a show
name no it's like santa's helpers or
something that is fat healthy yeah it
looks like it is fat [ __ ] it's not on
the thing but like but why would that be
your mentality i'm only gonna like i'm
gonna book fatty's
he just doesn't have a very high opinion
of people why would you not just why
would you not book it some other way
like you know like a freak show or like
fat [ __ ] like you know what it's like
because she's like me me and my friend
had an idea for a show where you only
book fatties but we're gonna tell them
ahead of time and it was gonna be like
called heavyweights and then it would be
like our one friend who lost a ton of
weight would be like the host of the
show and then everyone else would be a
fat [ __ ] but like it was like a fun and
good jest like it's hilarious yeah you
were friends with these yeah and we also
thought about doing like a like a
tiniest like show in austin and it's
like in the smallest little bar in
austin and then just only book little
shorties you know
it makes the place look huge yeah it's a
theater
um anyways but
what
jockey's are predominantly
comedic in nature jockeys
like little people no people like horses
uh little little people who ride horses
they don't let no they don't let big
they don't yeah there's they don't
choose tall people
imagine if you wanted to be a jockey so
bad that you amputated your bottom lips
so you could be a jockey and then you
like wouldn't know you overcome all the
odds it become like one of those like
inspirational sports films it's like sea
biscuit but for
you know it's called we biscuits it's i
can't see biscuit because he's too short
okay
mean this biscuit
he's just itching to get back to
wherever we were playing the recall game
no i'm good
let me do um
something let's do a where's the little
table
okay
roll call
my name is riley
i don't actually know my name is riley
i'm really smiley
roll call
let's freestyle
go for it
uh i can get my keyboard i'll go last
um
yeah i mean it's a conversation
what do you think about um derek default
what do you think about stop talking
look you can't even see him in the in
the camera because he's uh invisible
because he's such a monster he's gonna
show up on film
like who's in the scene tell me you guys
fill me in like i haven't been around
here filming it what's going on in the
scene we got i mean what are you
uh what's the haps
bro what
you heard me what what what do you think
about cryptocurrency or uh the future of
america uh i think that it's in a huge
bubble and it's everything's about to
become it's gonna it's not gonna be good
and i think people are really hopeful
and are like a little bit ignorant and
blind to what's about to [ __ ] happen
and uh it's not gonna it's gonna be a
transition of like power influence uh in
the next 20 years for sure and it's not
so it always it's gonna be a transfer
from like poor idiot rubes to douche bag
influencers
they're gonna walk out with all the
money
yeah but then it's gonna leave this
giant like there's gonna it's gonna be
pop i think it's like a really in
intense and large uh
like pork like plastic it's me like yeah
it's gonna be such a large gap and it'll
be classy as a class warfare and like
the pores are gonna lose like that's
just how it is
unless we have a french revolution
yeah poor's don't have to lose poor's
have a lot of guns at this point poor is
like i mean there's a lot of you know as
we i don't know i don't know
but the rich has the rich have the
government on their side so there's no
you can't well you can't this isn't
[ __ ] 1776 we don't but luckily
politicians look at afghanistan like 7
000 uh taliban could uh take over the
country because they had a force of will
yeah so if that can happen then we could
fight back with seven thousand
of ours yeah america is not a place
that's are we about to storm the capital
what the [ __ ]
oh my god
no i mean as long as bitcoin goes up
jesus is good
bitcoin goes down
there's not a lot going on i mean
there's not that much happening
and that we just like really in a
heightened state of super media
dramatization we're all just like always
feeling tense but if you just walk
around the day and go what happens like
well that happens
no it's not going to it's not going to
be great
yeah and it's just i don't know it's
like
one of my my my like this is not real
but like part of the things i think
sometimes is that uh
kobe's a uh conspiracy now that it's not
real or anything but like it's a
distraction for like wheeling and
dealing from the back of like the those
in power well it's like a giant slush
fund it's like a rainy day fund that we
all have access to it's like a 401k for
teachers
it's like we're all going to put our
money in here
and then the the slimiest one can get it
are you talking about bitcoin government
yeah yeah i don't know i don't
understand
sorry
i don't understand something
about the yeah whatever the world's the
world as you know it's gonna end and
like that's why i'm like so adamant
about people just living for like now
and doing the [ __ ] they want to do and
make them happy because it's not gonna
there's no point to living
because it's not gonna end well yeah
well and even if it does i mean what's
your loss that's the thing it's like
even let's say it goes another hundred
years or a thousand years or a billion
years and it all turns out great yes i
mean it's not like well it's not like
you did anything wrong because you're
like no i was like just living real i
was just trying to live like you know
it's like who's blaming you for living
every day you know yeah but we think we
think people are and people are because
they're being shameful about [ __ ] like
working 40 hours doing [ __ ] work i
mean the [ __ ] we do with our time it's
[ __ ] that's on the future
um i think that uh we're used to using
humans like cattle and we're used to
squeezing every
drop of work from them to get them to
flip burgers
uh
and that's subsidized by the government
with food stamps and all that
um but uh yeah i mean i think eventually
we're gonna find out that humans are in
cattle and the best way to utilize this
isn't for our manual labor which is
arithmetically going to increase our
benefit is creativity which is
exponential yeah like we could come up
with an invention that fixes all this
and instead of just using people for a
[ __ ]
like a cow that can have little fingers
like we can use people uh for more than
that yeah and then we can unleash our
potential and then
yeah robots will take yeah
that was my favorite thing